GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY THE FIRST BILL HERE ON
THE CA OF OUR AND A CHAIN SPORTS
AND MET ME OF THE TWENTY TWO ONE
TO TWO LETTERS SESSION CALLED
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOSS BURNER
WHERE- CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE I
WILL TO OUR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
MISSPELLING THEIR S.
ADDITIONALLY WILL BACK TO OUR
RETURN MEMBERS BUT BLOOM MISTER
CHOI DR CHOI THIS FREEMEN MISTER
NAZARIAN AND OUR NEWEST MEMBER
MIKE FONG- AND SO FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM. TODAY IN ROOM FOUR
FOUR FOUR MASTER NOT REQUIRED
BUT ARE ENCOURAGED. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION HEARD I ASK YOU
THAT YOU APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. FOR OUR DIAL AND
WITNESSES. TO ALSO BE USING A
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS
REMEMBER THE PUBLIC. MAY
ANNOUNCE THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN THAT'S
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. YOU MAY
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE DIALING IN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON. IS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION WILL ONLY TAKE
COMMENTS ON THE BILL THAT IS
BEING PRESENTED. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU'RE DIALING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTING YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTRACTION. SO THE- WE
HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT SO I'LL
ASK MANY SECRETARY TO NOW TAKE.
A TENANTS LOCAL. WE'RE BACK HERE
GALLAGHER IS HERE BLOOM HERE
CHOI YEAH FRIEDMAN. MIKE VON
HERE THE SYRIAN. ALL OF. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE
ITEM ON CONSENT. THE FINAL AYE
FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO TWO TWENTY
TWO TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA. SORRY
CALIFORNIA MAINSTREET PROGRAM WE
HAVE I HAVE A RECOMMENDATION OF
DO PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS THERE A MOTION
TO ADOPT THE CONSENT COUNTY.
OKAY SO WITH THAT COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BOERNER HORVATH HI CALAVERAS
BLOOM. CHOI FRIEDMAN MIKE FONG
HI NAZARIAN. OKAY WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN. AND WITH THAT WE'LL
GO TO FILE ITEM TO AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE MISTER BLOOM ARE YOU
READY PERCENT. THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA SORRY THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA CONCERT A FESTIVAL
CROWD SAFETY ACT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
TO THE CHAIRMANSHIP MADAM CHAIR. I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE WHICH
ESTABLISHES A SET OF MINIMUM
CROWD SAFETY STANDARDS USING
CROWDS SCIENCE AND OTHER BEST
PRACTICES TO GUIDE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WHEN PERMITTING
LARGE OUTDOOR EVENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN ORDER TO GUARANTEE
THE SAFEST EXPERIENCE POSSIBLE
FOR EVERYONE ATTENDING. OUTDOOR
CONCERTS AND FESTIVALS ARE
WONDERFUL WAY FOR FANS LIKE
MYSELF TO ENJOY LIVE MUSIC IN A
FUN INTERACTIVE AND ACCEPTING
ATMOSPHERE THERE ARE NUMEROUS
CONCERTS AND FESTIVALS HELD
EVERY YEAR OF COURSE AROUND THE
WORLD THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND
HUNDREDS THAT TAKE PLACE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MOST OF
THESE EVENTS- THANKFULLY
TRANSPIRED WITHOUT INCIDENT
HOWEVER THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER
OF CONCERTS AND FESTIVALS WHERE
DANGEROUS CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
RESULTED IN SERIOUS INJURY AND
LOSS EVEN LOSS OF LIFE FOR
CONCERT AND FESTIVAL GOERS
TRANSFORMING WHAT SHOULD BE A
JOYOUS AND MEMORABLE EXPERIENCE
INTO TRAGEDY. MOST CONCERTS AND
FESTIVALS ARE VERY WELL PLANNED
AND EXECUTED AND MOST CONCERT
AND FESTIVAL PROMOTERS AND
OPERATORS WORK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH COUNTY AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES. HOWEVER THE STATE
AT PRESENT DOES NOT HAVE A SET
OF MINIMUM SAFETY STANDARDS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
CONCERT THAT IS HELD THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IS AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE. THE DANGEROUS
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT UNFOLD DURING
THESE EVENTS ARE OFTEN
UNPREDICTABLE AND NOT ALL OF
THEM CAN BE PREVENTED BUT THEY
CAN'T BE PLANNED FOR. OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES CROWD
SCIENCE AND OTHER BEST PRACTICES
HAVE BEEN UTILIZED BY PROMOTERS
OR PICTURES AND SECURITY EXPERTS
TO HELP THEM FOR THE WORST CASE
SCENARIOS. THE APPLICATION OF
CROPSCIENCE AND OTHER BEST
PRACTICES HELP PROMOTERS
ORGANIZED AND PRETTY EXPERTS
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND PLAN FOR
CHANGES IN CROWD BEHAVIOR AND
MOOD THROUGH CROWD MODELING AND
OTHER METHODS WHICH CAN THEN BE
APPLIED DURING A LIVE EVENT. BY
PUTTING THESE MEASURES IN PLACE
PROMOTERS ORGANIZERS AND
SECURITY EXPERTS CAN ADDRESS
THESE DANGEROUS CIRCUMSTANCES
SAFELY AS THEY DEVELOP AND PUT
IN PLACE PROTOCOLS TO STOP A
CONCERT OR FESTIVAL OF THE
INCIDENT. IS DETERMINED TO POSE
AN IMMEDIATE THREAT TO LIFE OR
HEALTH AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE
IS A SENSIBLE MEASURE THAT HELPS
GUARANTEE THE SAFEST EXPERIENCE
POSSIBLE FOR EVERYONE THAT IS IN
ATTENDANCE AT AN ALCOVE OUTDOOR.
CONCERT OR FESTIVAL HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY
MARKET PRATT WHO IS HERE ON
BEHALF OF AG AND ZACH ALPERN THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR INSOMNIAC. A UNIT OF LIVE
NATION ENTERTAINMENT THAT
PROMOTES ELECTRONIC MUSIC
EVENTS. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- HAS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO GET MY NAME IS MARK A
PRAM WITH THE FIRM OF THE PREY
AND KAYLEE. AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF A E. G. AND H. G.
PRESENTS THE LIFE IN OUR-
DIVISION OF AG AND WE'RE PROUD
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWO SIX.
EIGHT ONE HEADQUARTERED IN LOS
ANGELES AG IS THE WORLD'S
LEADING SPORTS ENTERTAINMENT
COMPANY. AND HAS DEVELOPED WORLD
CLASS VENUES AS WELL AS MAJOR
SPORTS ENTERTAINMENT DISTRICTS
LIKE CRYPTO DOT COM ARENA
FORMALLY KNOWN AS STAPLES
CENTER. AND LA LIVE MERCEDES
BENZ AT MERCEDES PLOTS IN BERLIN
AND- THE O. TWO IN LONDON. EIJI
IS ALSO THE WORLD'S LARGEST
OPERATOR HIGH PROFILE SPORTING
EVENTS AND SPORTS FRANCHISES
INCLUDING THE LOS ANGELES KINGS
LOS ANGELES GALAXY AND ICE BEAR
IN BERLIN. FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS AGIUS PLACE WHEN DR NEW
STUDENTS HOWEVER I ASK THAT WE
ALSO CONSIDER WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE A STUDENT ON THE GROUND WITH
DETERIORATING QUALITY OF
EDUCATION. A STUDENT
SATISFACTION LEVEL WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO DECREASE IT IS. IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT SAY
ABOUT THE COULD NOT ASK FOR A
LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION WE
CANNOT HAVE A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH PROFESSORS.
AND THEY CAN ALSO NOT MAINTAIN
THEIR EDUCATION AND THE SAME WAY
ABOUT THE CLIENT HOUSING IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF BASS BUT ALSO
THE WAY IN WHICH WE CHOOSE TO
OPERATE THE INSTITUTION AND
EXPAND ITS OVERALL CAPACITY. IS
ALSO A MAJOR PART OF BASS. BUT
IF WE WANT TO CHOOSE TO DO THIS
I ASK BUT WE ALSO CONSIDER WHAT
WE CAN DO TO BE PROACTIVE RATHER
THAN REACTIVE. MANY OF THE
RESOURCES BY OUR CAMPUSES WORK
TO OFFER SUCH AS THESE HOUSING
VOUCHERS AND GRANTS ARE MEANT TO
SUPPLEMENT A STUDENTS INCOME OR
LACK OF INCOME TO AFFORD RENTS.
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT ENOUGH IF WE
SIMPLY CHOOSE TO BE REACTIVE WE
WILL NEVER GET TO THE HEART OF
THE ISSUE. THE HEART OF THE
ISSUE IS LACK OF HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITY THE HEART. IS THE
HEART OF THE ISSUE IS THE LACK
OF THE FORTY. EVEN WHEN WE HAVE.
I ALSO THOUGHT WE IT WASTE MAKE
OUR MORE EXCESSIVE BY INCH THAT
THE BAD STUFF OUR AVAIL IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE MORE AFFORDABLE
I ASKED BUT WE TRY TO MAKE THIS
MORE ACCESSIBLE BY ENSURING THAT
THE CONDITIONS BUT WE ASK
STUDENTS TO LIVE AND- ARE NOT.
INFERIOR TO THE WAY THAT WE
WOULD ASK OUR REGULAR CITIZENS
TO INTERACT WITH THEIR LIVING
CONDITIONS. AND LASTLY I ASKED
BUT WHEN WE CONSIDER HOUSING.
FOR STUDENTS I ASKED BUT WE
PRESSURE THE UC TO NOT ONLY MAKE
HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE BUT ALSO THAT WE
DON'T END UP WITH A DORM
PROJECTS SUCH AS THE MUNGER
DORMAN MY- CAMPUS. WE NEED
HOUSING BUT I'M ASKING BUT WE
HOUSE STUDENTS IN HUMANE
CONDITIONS AND A HAMSTER BOX
WHERE WE CAN JUST TRYING SHOT
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS FOR THE
SAKE OF IT. WITH FOUGHT BACK
INCLUDES MY REMARKS BINGO. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FIRST THOSE REALLY HELPFUL AND-
NEXT WE HAVE OUR REPRESENT THEM
FROM THAT CAL STATE STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION FABULA MARINO READ
LESS I THINK WE HAVE FAVIOLA ON
THE- WEBEX. RETAILERS ARE AFRAID
EVERYONE HEAR ME YEAH HE JUST
START TALKING REGARDING THANK
YOU OKAY OUR SON HELLO GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS FAR
ALONG WITH A NINE NINE HERE
REPRESENTING THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION ALSO A
FOURTH YEAR STUDENT AT AT SAN
DIEGO STATE GRADUATING THIS MAY
I CALIFORNIANS ARE NO STRANGERS
TO THE HOUSING CRISIS BUT THE
CRISIS AFFECTS STUDENTS IN WAYS
THAT CREATE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
IN THEIR PURSUIT OF A DEGREE.
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE HOUSING INFLATES THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE FOR OUR
STUDENTS SOME OF OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT STUDENTS FACE IN
TRYING TO FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS SEARCHING FOR A PLACE
TO LIVE BECAUSE MANY STUDENTS
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE A LOT OF
OPTIONS EACH CAMPUS COMMUNITY
AND THE CSU HAS THEIR OWN UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES BASED ON THE
VARIETY AND SKATES AND THE COST
OF LIVING ACROSS OUR STATE. OUR
CSU CAMPUSES IN SAN FRANCISCO
HUMBLED AT BAKERSFIELD ARE EACH
GOING TO HAVE DISTINCT NEEDS FOR
STUDENTS MANY STUDENTS ARE ALSO
ON THEIR OWN IN THEIR VERY FIRST
ATTEMPTS TO FIND SOMEWHERE TO
LIVE ON OR OFF CAMPUS STUDENTS
OFTENTIMES RUN INTO PROBLEMS OF
LANDLORDS HAVING QUICK
TURNAROUND TIMES FOR SIGNING THE
LEASE COMPLICATING THE HOUSING
SEARCH FOR STUDENTS TRYING TO
PLAN AHEAD. CEMEX IS. ARE THERE
MORE AFFORDABLE. AS FAR TO
LOOSEN FOR MANY STUDENTS AND
HOURS. WE CRIME SUCH AS A
DEPOSIT COAST. AND INCOME ARE
DIFFICULT TO ME RIGHT AWAY LOW
INCOME PARKS YOUTH. STUDENTS
BASED ECONOMY ARE AND ARE. WHAT
EXAMPLE A ROOM THAT INCLUDES A
MEAL PLAN AT S. COST SEVENTEEN
DOLLARS A SINGLE SPACE ALL
CAMPUS NEAR THIS YEAR CAN CATCH
CAN COST UP ABOUT DOLLARS. LET
ANALYSIS OFFICE AS THE A SIX
THOUSAND ELEVEN DOLLAR RANGE I'M
HOW. ARE ACTIVE THE YEAR
STUDENTS. I WOULD ALSO TO ADD
THAT A PRODUCT. 11% OF CSEC ARE
YOU TO HAVE AS HOME OR HOUSING.
THE ONSET OF THE COVENANTING
PANDEMIC HAS CAUSED EVEN GREATER
CHALLENGES FOR STUDENTS. CHANGES
WERE MOST PRONOUNCED AMONG THE
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS 65% OF
ITS WITH ZERO EFC REPORTED A
CHANGE AND THEIR LIVING
SITUATION COMPARED TO ONLY 57%
OF RESPONDENTS WITH GREATER THAN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS YES
THE- BY LOWERING THE- OF A- WITH
PROPER. AID WE LESSEN THE BURDEN
BACK HOUSING HAS ON STUDENTS
THAT IS WHY WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEGISLATORS PASS SUPPORT OF
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAME. THIS
YEAR WE ARE ONCE AGAIN ASKING
FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATORS AND THE GOVERNOR TO
SUPPORT PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE FINANCIAL AID THAT
ACTUALLY COVERS THE FULL COST OF
ATTENDANCE. HOUSING IS THE
GREATEST COSTS FOR STUDENTS IT
CAN BE DOUBLE OR TRIPLE THE COST
OF TUITION. YES ALSO THAT
LEGISLATORS REALLY TAKE THE TIME
TO KNOW THE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND OUR DISTRICT.
AND TO ASK QUESTIONS TO
UNDERSTAND THE UNIQUE HOUSING
CHALLENGES THAT STUDENTS BATES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY WITH A SECURE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT.
HOUSING TO LIVE STUDENTS CAN
GRADUATE DEBT FREE AND ON TIME.
FOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE- NEXT WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM PERSPECTIVE FROM A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT. YEAH
HI MY NAME IS JOHNSON PRASAD AND
I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REPRESENTING
OVER ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
NEARLY 60% OF OUR STUDENTS
REPORTER- THE FACING AT LEAST
ONE BASIC NEEDS INSECURITY WITH
THE RATES HIGHEST FOR MINORITY
STUDENT POPULATIONS DURING THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF THE PANDEMIC
. NEARLY THREE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
STUDENTS 57% REPORTED A- AT
LEAST ONE BASIC NEEDS INSECURITY
INCLUDING 40% REPORTING FOOD
INSECURITY. 37% REPORTING
HOUSING AND SECURITY AN 18%
REPORTING HOMELESSNESS. STUDENTS
WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO INDICATE
HOUSING IN SECURITIES WERE NOT
CONSIDERING RE ENROLLMENT. THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM HAS
ALREADY FACE A DECREASE OF
ENROLLMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE STUDENTS
DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP ON SCHOOL
BUT IT'S BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION. THE
SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE OUR
STUDENTS WHAT IS THE THING YOU
PERSONALLY NEED RIGHT NOW. THE
MOST FREQUENTLY CITED ANSWER WAS
FINANCIAL SYSTEM. THE SURVEY
FOUND THAT 26% OF STUDENTS
ANSWERED WITH FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THERE IS A QUOTE FROM
A STUDENT THAT STATES. WITHOUT
FINANCIAL AID THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ATTEND SCHOOL
DURING THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE OUR
ENTIRE FAMILY LOST THEIR JOBS
AND IT WAS HARD TO AFFORD
COLLEGE. ON TOP OF PAYING THEIR
BILLS. AS A STUDENT WHO QUALIFY
FOR PELL GRANT UNFORTUNATELY
QUALIFIES FOR CAL GRANT BUT DOES
NOT RECEIVE IT HAS BEEN A
STRUGGLE TO CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION AND ENSURING THAT I
CAN SEE ON THE PATHWAY THAT I
WANT AND GRADUATE WITH A DEGREE
THAT I DESIRE. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REALIZED THAT STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR FINANCIAL AID FOR
FIVE PLUS MORE YEARS AND THAT
IT'S BEEN STRONGER MORE THAN
EVER. AS THE THREE OF US SIT
HERE TODAY FABULOUS AS MAN NINE.
THREE WOMAN EMPOWER REPRESENTING
UNDER REPRESENTED POPULATIONS
STEEP. ALL FISH HOUSING IN
SECURITIES IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REALIZE THAT MANY STUDENTS ARE
GOING THROUGH THE SAME STRUGGLE.
WE ARE REPRESENTING OUR STUDENTS
ON EVERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUS UC OR CSU TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE NEED THESE RESOURCES SO
WE CAN CONTINUE OUR EDUCATIONAL
POP WAY ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I SOMEONE WHO USED HOW
GRANT TO COVER MOST OF THEIR
TUITION IT DOESN'T COVER THE
FULL COST SUCH AS TEXTBOOKS
WHICH WE ALL KNOW COST UP TO TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY MY CASE SOMETIMES
TO SELL MYSELF BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE COURSE ONLINE ACCESS CODE
THAT WE ALSO PAY FOR. AND IT'S
REALLY UNFORTUNATE THAT WE EE
OUR STUDENTS INCREASING IN A
MOMENT JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD THE COST OF COLLEGE. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT SOME FOR
AFFORDABLE FOR STUDENTS SO THEY
CAN CONTINUE IN PROVIDE BACKED
HER WORKFORCE. SO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE PASSIONATE AND ARE
EAGER TO LEARN AND PURSUE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL DEGREE. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THEY'RE BEING
STOPPED BY THESE SYSTEMATIC
BARRIERS THAT ARE PREVENTING
THEM TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION. AND I THOUGHT I
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS TO
LISTEN TO STUDENTS AND
ESPECIALLY THE FIX FINANCIAL AID
COALITION WHICH WE ALL
REPRESENT. TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED THIS YEAR AND THAT THE FULL
FRAMEWORK IS MATT FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS TO PER THROUGH THEIR
HIGHER. EDUCATION CAREER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND IT WAS HELPFUL
TO HEAR FROM OUR STUDENTS- AND
THEN WE'LL GET TO THE- THE
ACTUAL PROPOSALS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WERE INCLUDING IN IN THE
NEXT YEAR A BUDGET WE HAD A
MAJOR HEARING ON THIS AS WE KNOW
THIS FALL. WE TALKED ABOUT THE
INTERIM- APPLICATIONS COMING IN
FROM LAST YEAR'S ALLOCATION SO
NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALEJO IN
THE SEGMENTS ABOUT THAT AND
POTENTIAL ACTION FOR- FOR GOING
FOR IT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU YEAH. SEVEN
YOU BRING UP DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE L. A. O. AND- WELL FED
UP THERE YEAH AND THE THREE
SEGMENTS. HELLO.
NOT GOOD OKAY WE'RE GONNA START
WITH JENNIFER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS JENNIFER
COFFEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS PART OF MY REMARKS I
WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF BACKGROUND
ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR. FINANCES
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
THAT WERE DUE ON MARCH FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THEN THE
PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INVESTMENT. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT ESTABLISHED THE
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM WHICH SET ASIDE
TWO BILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD.
TO ESTABLISH A LOW COST STUDENT
HOUSING GANT PROGRAM FOR THE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS. FOCUSED ON EXPANDING
THE AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING. A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROGRAMSB ONE
SIXTY NINE APPROPRIATED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FOR THE FIRST
INSTALLMENT OF FUNDING. OF THE
APPROPRIATED FUNDING UP TO
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS AVAILABLE
TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO SUPPORT PLANNING GRANTS TO
DETERMINE IF IT IS FEASIBLE FOR
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
CONSTRUCT. AN OFFER AFFORDABLE
STUDENT RENTAL HOUSING. ON MARCH
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SUBMITTED
A LETTER TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WITH A LIST OF RECOMMENDED
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO BE
FUNDED IN THE FIRST ROUND OF
FUNDING. A LIST OF ELIGIBLE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT RECOMMENDING
BE FUND FUNDED OUT OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION APPROPRIATED FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND A LIST OF PROJECTS THAT
FINANCING TERM TO BE AN ELIGIBLE
. FOR THE AVAILABLE CONSTRUCTION
GRANT FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRIORITIZE SUPPORT FOR
PROPOSED PROJECTS. THAT ROUGHLY
RIVER THAT REFLECTED IT INTER
SEGMENTAL HOUSING ARRANGEMENT.
AND THEN PRIORITIZED FURTHER
APPLICATIONS BASED UPON A
WEIGHTED RANKING THAT COMPLIANT
THAT COMBINED AN APPLICANT STATE
SUPPORTED PER BED. CONSTRUCTION
COSTS AND AN APPLICANT'S
PROPOSED OVER STUDENT RENTAL
RATES. IN THAT LETTER TO THE
JAIL BC FINANCE ALSO SUBMITTED A
LIST OF PLANNING GRANTS TO BE
AWARDED TO COLLEGES REQUESTING
PLANNING GRANTS AND PLANNING
GRANT FUNDING WAS PRIORITIZE. TO
SUPPORT EARLY STAGE PLANNING
ACTIVITY ACTIVITIES FOR ALL
COLLEGES REQUESTING PLANNING
GRANTS. FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE SECOND INSTALLMENT
OF THE PLAN TWO BILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION FOR
THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. DO CONCENTRA SOLELY-
BEFORE I DELVE INTO OUR
COMMENTS- JUST FUTURE FOLLOWING
ALONG IN THE AGENDA. OF PAGE
FOR- SUMMARIZES THE PROJECTS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
RECOMMENDING TO SELECT FOR ROUND
ONE GRANTS. H. FIVE DISPLAYS ALL
OF THE PROPOSED PLANNING GRANTS
THAT THEIR- ADMINSTRATION'S
PROPOSING. AND THEN ON PAGE SIX
THAT FIRST TABLE ARE THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE ALSO DEEMED
ELIGIBLE FOR GRANTS BUT- AREN'T
RANKED LOWER AND THUS ARE NOT
BEING PROPOSED FOR ROUND ONE
GRANTS. AND THEN I FINAL TABLE
ON PAGE SIX ARE OF THE PROJECTS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION-
DETERMINED TO BE INELIGIBLE FOR
ROUND ONE GRANTS. AND THEN JUST
TO CLARIFY THE LEGISLATURE'S
ROLE IN THIS PROGRAM- UNDER THE
PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE OR ALTERNATELY
TASKED WITH REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS AND SELECTING-
PROJECTS FOR ROUND ONE GRANTS.
THEIR ADMINISTRATION HAS
SUBMITTED A PROPOSAL- BUT
ULTIMATELY IT'S THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR THAT MUST
DECIDE ON THE- FINAL OUT.
PROJECTS TO BE FUNDED THROUGH ON
ONE GRANTS. SO THAT'S REALLY THE
ISSUE BEFORE THIS- COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW. WE OFFER THREE. SETS
OF. COMMENTS THAT I WILL QUICKLY
GO THROUGH A HIGH LEVEL AND THEN
WE CAN ELABORATE MORE DURING THE
Q. AND A- OUR FIRST SET OF
COMMENTS ARE- AROUND THE MANY
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO. ON SITE
PROJECTS. NOW WHEN WE REVIEWED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WE
THOUGHT IT TO BE REASONABLE AT
GENERALLY ALIGNED WITH THE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES SET FORTH IN
STATUTE. BUT THERE ARE MANY
OTHER APPROACHES THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TAKE- AND NOT KEEPING THAT
IN MIND RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE START WEIGHING THESE
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES AGAINST
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
AN ATTORNEY WHICH ONE OF WHICH
OPTIONAL LINES WITH ITS
OBJECTIVES FOR THE A PROGRAM.
NOW NOTE THAT YOU'LL VERY LIKELY
HEAR A LOT OF IDEAS IN TERMS OF
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES THAT YOU
COULD TAKE. WE OFFER SOME
ALTERNATIVE IDEAS ON PAGES SEVEN
AND EIGHT OF YOUR AGENDA. AND
THEN STAFF OFFER SOME ADDITIONAL
IDEAS ON PAGE TEN. AND I SUSPECT
YOU'LL HEAR EVEN A SOME
ADDITIONAL- IDEAS FROM THE
SEGMENTS. AS YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH THESE DIFFERENT OPTIONS-
YOU KNOW FUNDAMENTALLY IT MIGHT
BE HELPFUL TO START WITH WHAT
ARE THE GOALS FOR THE PROGRAM.
IF THE GOALS ARE SOLELY ABOUT
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. IS A
STARTING POINT TO GET THEIR- IF
YOU HAVE MANY OTHER OBJECTIVES
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU WANT TO FOCUS
IN AREAS THAT HAVE HIGH HOUSING
SHORTAGES IN HIGH DEMAND. OR IF
YOUR FOCUS IS ON ENROLLMENT
CAPACITY. THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
YOU COULD MODIFY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
MORE EXPLICITLY CONSIDER THOSE
FACTORS. SO AGAIN IT'S REALLY
GOING TO. FALL ON WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE FOR- FOR THIS
PROGRAM. HEY CAN HAPPY DURING
THE CUNY TO ELABORATE MORE ON
ANY IDEAS THAT YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT. OUR SECOND SET OF
COMMENTS ARE AROUND THE VARIOUS
PROGRAM RISKS THAT- WE THINK ARE
PRESENT IN THIS PROGRAM. NOW ALL
CAPITAL OUTLAY- PROJECTS COME
WITH SOME RISKS YOU KNOW THEY
COME WITH THE RISK OF HAVING
COST OVERRUNS COMING IN AT A
DIFFERENT SCOPE OR HAD FACING
IMPLEMENTATION DELAYS. WE THINK
THESE RISKS ARE PARTICULARLY
SALIENT IN THIS PROGRAM FOR TWO
REASONS ONE IS THAT CAMPUSES
GENERALLY HAVE LESS EXPERIENCE-
CONSTRUCTING OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE THE COLLEGES
THAT HAVE. LITTLE EXPERIENCE-
ONE THING HOUSING PROGRAMS
GENERALLY. AND THEN SUDDENLY-
CUT COST OVERRUNS SCOPE CHANGES
COULD PUT THE STATE LEGISLATURE
DIFFICULT POSITION. ON MAY COULD
PUT PRESSURE ON THE CAMPUSES TO
ALTER THEIR SCOPES R OR
INCREASE THE PROPOSED RENTS
THEREBY UNDERMINING THE GOALS OF
THE PROGRAM OR COULD PUT
PRESSURE ON THE STATE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING- TO HELP
COVER THESE COST OVERRUNS.
KEEPING THIS IN MIND WE
RECOMMEND A THREE STATUTORY
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM THAT WE
THINK WILL HELP MITIGATE SOME OF
THESE RISKS. AGAIN FOR THE SAKE
OF TIME I WON'T GO THROUGH THEM
AND BIG DETAIL DURING MY
TESTIMONY BUT HAPPY TO ELABORATE
MORE ON THE Q. AND A- BUT THE
FOCUS ON ENSURING THAT THERE'S
FUNDING FOR CONTINGENCY.
ESTABLISHING A NOTIFICATION
PROCESS FOR THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
THERE ARE NOTABLE SCOPE CHANGES.
AND ALSO ENHANCING SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS EXISTING REPORTING
REQUIREMETS. FOR OUR FINAL SET
OF COMMENTS OR AROUND THE
VARIOUS PRIVATE HIGHER EDUCATION
PRIORITIES LEGISLATORS FACING
THIS YEAR- AS YOU AS THIS
COMMITTEE IS DISCUSSED MANY
TIMES THEY'RE STILL SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF UNMET FINANCIAL NEED
AT THE SEGMENTS PARTICULARLY AT
THE CAL STATE IN THE COMMUTER
COLLEGE SYSTEMS. AND THAT'S JUST
BECAUSE OF THE GAP BETWEEN
EXISTING FINANCIAL AID SPENDING
AND THE LEVEL OF FINANCIALLY
THAT EXISTS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. EVEN ONCE ALL THESE
GRANTS ARE ALLOCATED THAT
AFFORDABILITY GAP WILL STILL
REMAIN. ADDITIONALLY THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALSO FACING MANY
ISSUES WITH ACADEMIC FACILITIES
AT THE SEGMENTS RELATED TO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SEISMIC
SAFETY ISSUES THIS COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE MANY TIMES.
AND THIS ISSUE WILL REMAIN EVEN
AFTER THE GRANTS ARE FULLY
ALLOCATED. GIVEN ALL THESE
COMPETING ISSUES WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE START THINKING
ABOUT WHICH OF THESE AREAS ARE
AMONG THE TIRES PRIORITIES. AND
REALLY FOCUS ITS RESOURCES ON
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS. THANK YOU
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS HAPPY TO
ELABORATE MORE IN Q. NAY. OKAY
THANK YOU NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR- THREE SEGMENTS WHAT WE'LL
START WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE WAS EVER
AT- EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT AND
SUCCESS OF THE CALIFORNIA ME
COLLEGES OVER THE PAST DECADE
HOMELESSNESS HAS BEEN ON THE
RISE ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA MEAN
COLLEGES STUDENTS ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN THE HOUSING
CRISIS AS OUR STUDENT LEADER
SHARED THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE A STATE BUDGET PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS- THE
HOUSING CRISIS WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING AFFORDABILITY HOUSING
WITH DIGNITY AND A COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS. FURTHER YET
IT'S ANOTHER STRATEGY TOWARD
STUDENT SUCCESS ON AVERAGE OUR
STUDENTS SPEND FOURTEEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO
DOLLARS PER YEAR ON HOUSING
THAT'S TEN TIMES MORE THAN THEY
SPEND ON TUITION AND FEES.
CURRENTLY TWELVE ME COLLEGES
ACROSS THE SYSTEM HAVE STUDENT
HOUSING AND WE HAVE CAPACITY FOR
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BEDS THAT'S NOWHERE NEAR
THE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. THE PROPOSED- AND
ELIGIBLE HOUSING- PROGRAMS ARE
PROJECTS THAT WERE SUBMITTED TO
YOU BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COULD MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
STUDENT HOUSING THAT WE HAVE
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM SO WE THINK.
IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER INVESTMENTS THIS YEAR.
EFFORTS TO BUILD A HOLISTIC
STUDENT HOUSING NEEDS FRAMEWORK
MUST INCLUDE A ROBUST FOCUS ON
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AND THAT
IS A KEY DISTINCTION WITHIN THE
PROJECT THAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU
FORM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO WE
SUGGEST THE BUILDING ON THE ONE-
BILLION COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. OF
AWARDING THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED TO YOU I'M BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT ALSO-
AND THOSE INCLUDE- FIVE PROJECTS
ASSIST USE FRESNO IMPERIAL
SIERRA AND VENTURA. BUT WE ALSO
ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THE ELIGIBLE PROJECTS THAT THOSE
CAN MOVE FORWARD NOW- SO THAT
YOU CAN PREVENT COST ESCALATION
AND HELP US REACH THAT GOAL OF
MORE THAN DOUBLING THE STUDENT
HOUSING AVAILABLE ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM. THAT WOULD MEAN FUNDING
FOR A AND BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE OF
THE CANYONS COMPTON BECAUSE SOME
THIS RIVER LAKE TAHOE NAPA AND
SANTA ROSA- SEVERAL OF THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN FIRE AFFECTED
AREAS ACROSS OUR STATE
STRUGGLING WITH HOUSING
GENERALLY. THE PROPOSED AN
ELIGIBLE COULD ENSURE THAT WE
ARE MOVING FASTER AND- MORE
EFFICIENTLY TOWARDS BUILDING-
HOUSING ACROSS OUR SYSTEM IN
BUILDING THAT CAPACITY TO
ADDRESS BASIC NEEDS AND
AFFORDABILITY. WE ALSO- ART
COMMAND TODAY PROPOSED. ELIGIBLE
PRODUCTS- AND PLANNING GRANTS OF
THE APPROACH THAT WAS TAKEN BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH
ENSURES THAT ALL SEVENTY FIVE
APPLICANTS CAN RECEIVE SOME
RESOURCES TO BEGIN ANALYZING THE
FEASIBILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
BRING BEGIN THE IMPORTANT STEPS-
OF ENSURING THOSE PROJECTS.
LASTLY THE CALIFORNIA
MYCOLOGISTS CANCERS OFFICE IS
COMMITTED TO BUILDING THE STATE
WIDE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
NEEDED TO. AB ACCOUNTABLE ALL-
HOUSE PROJECTS THAT INCLUDES-
ADDING DATA ELEMENTS WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY NOT COLLECTED- IN OUR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAM KNOWN AS
FUSION. PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A HOLISTIC SERVICES ALONG WITH
HOUSING- THAT- MEETS CLEARY ACT
REPORTING TITLE NINE AMONGST
OTHER KEY ELEMENTS THAT STUDENTS
RELY ON. AND LASTLY THE BARRIERS
THAT MANY OF OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS FACE ARE ROOTED IN
POVERTY AND SOCIAL ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGES MOST OF WHICH-
MANIFEST IN HOUSING AND SECURITY
SO MOVING TO AN ERA MOVING FROM
A RIGHT TO FAIL ERA TO A STUDENT
SUCCESS ERA EMBRACES THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS REQUIRES RETHINKING
AND EXPANDING. NONACADEMIC
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS SUCH A
STUDENT HOUSING SO WE COMMEND
YOUR EFFORTS AND INVESTMENTS
STUDENT HOUSING AND ARE READY TO
PARTNER AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR INVESTMENT IN OUR COLLEGES
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT WILL GO TO CSU.
GOOD MORNING THE VIRUS AND ONE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
CAPITAL PLANNING DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION FOR THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY. THE CSU ASKED THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE POINT
SEVEN MILLION SO JUST UNDER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION. OF
THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
ENVISIONED OF THE MULTI YEAR
PROGRAM FOR THE CSU. THE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IS- ENVISIONED
OVER THREE YEARS SO WE ARE
ASKING FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER ADVANCING DOLLARS AHEAD
OF THE YEAR ONE AND TWO AND INTO
A LITTLE BIT OF YOUR THREE. THE
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY NINE MILLION
IS COMPRISED OF FUNDING FOR NEW
PROJECTS OF THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE MILLION. AND FIFTY
MILLION TO BEGIN A NEW DIRECT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM FOR
STUDENTS. SO THAT THE- SHEET
THAT'S BEEN HANDED OUT IS THE-
OBJECTS WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
APPROVAL ON. THE FIRST TWO
PROJECTS ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RECOMMENDATION AND THE REMAINING
PROJECTS FOLLOWED BOARD OF
TRUSTEES PRIORITIES AND YOU CAN
SEE ON THIS FOR SPREAD SHEET THE
BOARD CONSIDERED. THE SINCE
START DATE THE AMOUNT OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AT THE CAMPUS
THE BED CAPACITY THE CAMPUS AS
FAR AS FACTORS THAT DROVE THOSE
PROJECTS TO BE A HIGHER PRIORITY
. THE INTERSEC METAL PROJECT AT
IBC IS ARE THE TOP PRIORITY
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTERSEGMENT
APPROACH TAKEN BY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE SPREADSHEET SHOWS
THAT THE CSU WAS PROPOSING CO
FUNDING SO THE STATE GRANT FUNDS
WOULD LEVERAGE CSU FUNDS AND IT
WOULD ENABLE THE COST PER BED TO
BE REDUCED BY FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR BED. SO
WITH THE AFFORDABLE STUDENT
GRANT FUNDING THE COST PER BED
REDUCES TO ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND PER BED. IN THE
SPLIT BETWEEN THE GRANT FUNDS
AND CSU FUNDING WOULD BE 65%
GRANT FUNDING 35% C. S. USE OF
BOND FINANCING. THE SECOND THE
CSU PROPOSES THE STATUE BE
BROADENED TO ALLOW FOR
RENOVATIONS TO INCREASE OCCUPANT
DENSITY IN EXISTING FACILITIES.
AND THE IDEA THAT WE TARGET AN
AMOUNT OF THE FUNDS TO PROVIDE
HOUSING GRANTS DIRECTLY TO
STUDENTS. SO IF ALLOWED
RENOVATION PROJECTS COULD BE
SUBMITTED FOR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR THE
THIRD YEAR OF THE PROGRAM. END
OF WE'VE PROVIDED TO COMMITTEE
STAFF A STRIKE THROUGH ON
PROPOSED DETAILS ON STATUTE
CHANGES FOR THE USE. THE
RENOVATIONS WE WOULD PROMOTE OR
THOSE PROJECTS WHICH ALLOW US TO
INCREASE DENSITY TO GO FROM TWO
BEDS TO THREE. AND PRIMARILY
ADDRESS FIRE SPRINKLERS FIRE
SAFETY NEEDS IN THE PROJECT
EGRESS- AND ALARM SYSTEMS. BUT
WE ALSO HAVE TO ADDRESS CODE
UPGRADES THAT ARE REQUIRED SO
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. ADA BUT IN BY
ALLOWING RENOVATION PROJECTS TO
BE. ELIGIBLE IT WOULD REDUCE THE
COST FOR BED. THE SECOND CHANGE
IN STATUTE WOULD ALLOW THIS
PORTION OF GRANT FUNDS TO BE
USED FOR DIRECT GRANTS. FIFTY
MILLION IS THE NUMBER WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN WEEK WOULD RUN
ADDITIONAL NUMBERS LOOKING AT-
HOW WE WOULD SET UP AN ENDOWMENT
FUND. THAT THE THOUGHT IS TO
REDUCE THE COST. TO MEET THE
STATUTE REQUIREMENT THE 30% TO
FIFTY PERCENT. AND OF AN NFL
ENABLE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE
VACANCY. TWO IT OFFER THOSE
STUDENTS BEDS NOW SO THEY COULD
BE OFFERED AS SOON AS FALL
VERSUS HAVING TO WAIT FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION AND CONSTRUCTION.
WHICH WOULD GO OUT POLICE MAYBE
FALL OF TWENTY FIVE SO THERE'D
BE IMMEDIATE BENEFIT TO STUDENTS
IF. HE WERE TO AGREE. IT ALSO
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE CERTAINTY
ISSUES RAISED BY THE LA- WITH
THE RISK OF CONSTRUCTION AND THE
COST ESCALATION THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR TO WEST 8%
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
THEY WERE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MANAGE THAT FOR THE
PROJECTS WITHIN THE GRANT
FUNDING. THE PLAN WOULD BE FOR
ALL STUDENTS ALL STUDENTS TO USE
THEIR FEDERAL AND STATE.
FINANCIAL AID FIRST. AND LOOK AT
THOSE STUDENTS WITH STILL
REMAINING UNMET NEEDS BEFORE
THEY'D HAVE TO TAKE OUT A LOAN.
SO THIS APPROACH WOULD BE
POTENTIAL YEAH NOT ONLY THE
FASTER BENEFIT BUT IT INCREASES
THE AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IT SUPPORTS OUR GRAD IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN BALANCES OUT
AVAILABILITY SO WE'RE WE HAVE
BEDS AGAINST. AFFORDABILITY AND
SOME BEDS ARE ARE OPEN NOW OWNER
OCCUPANCY RATES ARE LOW BECAUSE
OF CODED SO WE HAVE SOME FALSELY
LOW. VACANCY RATES BUT WE HAVE
CAMPS THE DO HAVE VACANCIES THAT
WE COULD OFFER VERY QUICKLY. SO
IN SUMMARY THE CSU REQUEST IS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
FOR A COMBINATION OF NEW
PROJECTS AND THE NEW DIRECT
STUDENT GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU
. OKAY THANK YOU LESLIE YEAH YOU
SEE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING TERM
ACCARDI CHAIR TANG MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY I'M SAY
EVER TENANTS SPEAKING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA VIEWS
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING IS A
KEY COMPONENT OF AN AFFORDABLE
EDUCATION ACCESS TO SAFE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ALLOW
STUDENTS TO FOCUS ON THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS AVAILABILITY
OF CAMPUS HOUSING PROVIDES
STUDENTS WITH OPTIONS OF LIVING
BOTH ON OR OFF CAMPUS EITHER ONE
ADDITIONALLY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOUND A LINK
BETWEEN STUDENT RETENTION AND
THE AVAILABILITY OF FIRST YEAR
HOUSING. SINCE MANY OF OUR
CAMPUSES ARE LOCATED IN VERY
HIGH COST RENTAL AREAS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BEGAN TO STUDENT
HOUSING INITIATIVE- THIS
INITIATIVE HOW THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING FOURTEEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL NEW STUDENT HOUSING
BEDS ACROSS THE SYSTEM. AND IT
WAS EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL AND BY-
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE HAD
EXCEEDED THE GOAL AND PROVIDED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND NEW STUDENT
HOUSING BEDS ACROSS OUR SYSTEM.
CAMPUSES ARE PLANNING ON
CONTINUING TO EXPAND THE
AVAILABILITY OF STUDENT HOUSING
AND OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
PLANNING TO CONSTRUCT ANOTHER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENT
BEDS ACROSS OUR CAMPUSES. OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF ST IS
STRATEGICALLY UTILIZING A
VARIETY OF- FINANCING VEHICLES
FOR STUDENT HOUSING. TO SECURE
LOW COST FINANCING AND
TRANSFERRED THAT INTO A GREATER
AFFORDABILITY. IN A RECENT
STUDENT HOUSING EXPANSION WE USE
BOTH LIMITED REVENUE LIMITED
PROJECT REVENUE BONDS AND PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS ARE P.
THREES TO FINANCE PROJECTS.
BECAUSE INTEREST RATES WERE LOW
UNTIL RECENTLY WE WERE ABLE TO
FINANCE PROJECTS AT 3% OR LESS-
BEFORE INTEREST RATES START
RISING- IT COST YOU SEE AN
AVERAGE OF TWO HUNDRED TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER BED
TO COMPLETE A NEW HOUSING
PROJECT. THAT EQUATED TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR EVERY FOUR
HUNDRED NEW CAMPUS HOUSING BEDS
ADDED TO THE SYSTEM. AS INTEREST
RATES AND INFLATION RISE WE
EXPECT THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION
TO ALSO INCREASE. THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WILL PROVIDE STATE FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION THESE GRANT FUNDS
WILL ASSIST IN KEEPING THE
PROJECT UP TO A MINIMUM.
OFFERING MORE LOW INCOME STUDENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAMPUS
OPTIONS- THE HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW ON SEPTEMBER
TWENTY THIRD AND THE FIRST
APPLICATIONS WERE DUE ON OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST- DESPITE THAT VERY
TIGHT TURNAROUND SIX CAMPUSES
SUBMITTED PROJECTS- FOR A TOTAL
OF SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN GRANT
FUNDING. THE CONSTRUCT ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED NEW
STUDENT BEDS- WE RANK THESE
PROJECTS BASED ON THE STATE COST
PER BED WHEN WE SENT THEM OVER
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
WANT TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR THEIR REVIEW OF
THESE PROJECTS AND REQUEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA PROJECTS
RECOMMENDED FOR FUNDING- THESE
INCLUDE A THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT TO UCLA TO
CONSTRUCT THREE HUNDRED. FIFTY
EIGHT NEW BEDS THE PROJECT WILL
HAVE A CAMPUS MATCH OF TWENTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- OF THE ANTICIPATED
OCCUPANCY WILL BEGIN IN FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR GRANT TO
UC SAN DIEGO TO CONSTRUCT ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED EIGHT NEW
BEDS- THAT THAT PROJECT WILL
HAVE A CAMPUS MATCH OF TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION- AND
ANTICIPATED OCCUPANCY BEGINNING
IN FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THINK THEY'RE HIKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MUNGER HALL. YES
HOPEFULLY YOU COULD STILL HEAR
WATER OPPOSE THE MUNGER HALL.
WHAT IT WHAT ARE THEY TALKING
ABOUT THAT. MUNGER HALL I DID
SUPPORT- OR OPPOSE MUNGER HALL
THERE THANKING I THINK THEY'RE
PROBABLY OPPOSED TO ALMOST
EVERYTHING. THE HER- AND THEN IN
ADDITION UC MERCED- JOINTLY WITH
MERCED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
RECEIVED A PLANNING GRANT OF
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS- BY STATUTE UC'S
ELIGIBLE 420% OF THE- HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT.
FOR THAT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
THAT MEANS FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
IN- GRANTS DO YOU SEE IN THIS
FIRST YEAR WE APPLIED FOR SIX
HUNDRED MILLION SO WE ARE
ALREADY OVER PRESCRIBED BY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION JUST WITH YOU
SEE PROJECTS- IN ADDITION TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM THE LEGISLATURE IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING A ZERO
INTEREST REVOLVING LOAN FUND.
FOR STUDENTS STAFF AND FACULTY
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION SUCH A
REVOLVING LOAN FUND COULD
PROVIDE YOU SEE WITH LONG TERM
SUSTAINED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
BY ALLOWING TO UNIVERSITY TO
REDEPLOY THE PRINCIPAL. PAYMENTS
ON NEW PROJECTS AND PROVIDE
SAVINGS ON THE INTEREST EXPENSE
- THE SAVINGS COULD BE PASSED ON
TO THE STUDENTS THE FORM OF
LOWER RENT- OR FINANCIAL AID AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE- TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROPOSED FUND WORKS
OPERATIONALLY FOR OUR CAMPUSES I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU. SAYS
TESTING MY PATIENCE WE HAVE LOTS
OF NOISE IN THE HALLWAY LOTS OF
HONKING AT THEIR OLD WINDOWS BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT THE SHOW GOES ON
SO STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
FACING OUR STRUGGLE SO WE CAN
DEAL WITH THIS IN HERE. SO I
WANT TO START BY ASKING EACH-
FIRST OF ALL THIS IS A BIG ISSUE
THAT WE'RE KNOWLEDGE IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY
CALIFORNIA. MAYBE THE STATE
SHOULD GET. INVOLVED IN STUDENT
HOUSING WE JUST LET IT HAPPEN ON
ITS OWN. AND OBVIOUSLY THE UC
AND CSU HAVE A MAJOR PRIORITY
BECAUSE YOUR- UNDERGRADUATES
LIVE ON CAMPUS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES NOT SO MUCH. AS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN COMMUTERS
SOME CAMPUSES HAVE STUDENT
HOUSING. BUT I THINK THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT BECAUSE OF THE-
HOUSING CRISIS OVERALL AND JUST
THE FACT THAT HOUSING COSTS SO
MUCH OF THE STUDENTS- YOU KNOW
THE LOAD OF STUFF THAT FOR DEBT
LOAD OF STUDENTS AND JUST YOU
KNOW- DEMAND ON CAMPUSES THAT WE
NEED TO STEP UP AND FOCUS ON
STUDENT HOUSING SO WE DECIDED TO
DO THAT THE QUESTION IS AS THE
L. A. O. SAID YOU KNOW WHAT DO
WE DO WITH OUR RESOURCES I THINK
LAST YEAR- I KNOW MR TANG WAS
TALK ABOUT THIS TO BE PUT MONEY
FOR NEW HOUSING AND EXPANSION
BUT JUST FOCUSING ON JUST THE
HOUSING FOR A SECOND WE PUT. THE
MONEY LAST YEAR FOR A 100% OF
THE MONEY TO FUND THE FUND FOR
PROJECTS WHICH IS GREAT FOR THE
WINNERS BUT WE'RE PICKING A FEW
WINNERS AMBER PICKING A LOT OF
LOSERS I'M THINKING ABOUT LIKE
YOU KNOW I KNOW I HAVE TWO
TEENAGE GIRLS SAYS MR O'DONNELL
SAYS MR TAN IF WE WENT TO EACH
ONE OF OUR KIDS GAVE ONE AN
AMAZING PRESENT AND THE OTHER.
SORRY I DON'T HAVE A FOR YOU OR
GIVE EACH OF THEM A GOOD PRESENT
SO I'M I'M I'M THINKING THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD RETHINK THIS AND
NOT GIVE A 100% THE PROJECTS BUT
GIVE 20% OR JUST- DOING
PROPOSING ARE LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR AND DO 100% ZERO INTEREST-
LOANS SO WE CAN PICK MORE
PROJECTS AND NOT YOU KNOW- PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS SO. AND WE
SEE THIS THE PROJECTS THAT WE
HAVE THE APPLICATIONS FOR WE HAD
TONS OF PROJECTS THAT WE'RE
SORRY WE YOU KNOW GET YOU NEXT
TIME AND WE PROBABLY WON'T GET
THAT IF YOU GO WITH THE STATUS
QUO OF MY PLAN SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION STARTING FOR EACH
SEGMENT IS IF YOU WOULD YOU
PREFER. TO HAVE A 100% FINANCING
FOR A FEW OF YOUR PROJECTS OR
HAVE IT MORE BROAD AND HAVE YOU
KNOW- HALF THE GRANT OR OR USE
IT FOR A HUNDRED PERCENT- ZERO
INTEREST ON LIKE I KNOW SOME UC
CHANCELLORS ARE ARE RECOMMENDING
SO IF YOU COULD NOT PICKING AT
EACH SEGMENT START WITH THAT
SOURCE. CSU PICTURE. THIS IS SO
LOOKING AT THE PROPOSED SUB OF
THE FOR MILLION I THINK
OPTIMALLY WE WOULD HAVE PROPOSED
EQUIVALENT OF A SIX HUNDRED BED
NEW CONSTRUCTION WHICH IS
PROBABLY CLOSER TO EIGHTY
MILLION AND IF WE COULD HAVE SIX
HUNDRED BEDS MADE AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM FOR
STUDENTS IT WOULDN'T MATTER
WHICH CAMPUS IT WAS SO WE COULD
WE COULD PROVIDE STUDENT HOUSING
GRANTS AFTER THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AFTER CAL GRANT BE
AVAILABLE IMMEDIATELY AND WE
COULD HIT. AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO NO MAY EAST BAY
BAKERSFIELD SAMBAR DINO WHERE
THERE HAVE SOME ENROLLMENT
CHALLENGES. AND MAYBE THAT WOULD
HELP THEM LET ME ASK THE
QUESTION IF MAYBE HE COMES MAYBE
I DIDN'T SAY IT CORRECTLY SO. IF
I HAD. A BAG HERE. OF A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR CSU. WOULD YOU
RATHER. TAKE THAT IN FUND LET'S
SAY FIVE PROJECTS AT A 100% AT
FIVE YOU'RE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES OR- YOU KNOW- PARTIALLY
FIND MORE PROJECTS SO THEY COULD
ALL MORE BE FINANCIALLY VIABLE
WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU. WHAT WOULD
YOU DO. SET SO WHAT WE DID WAS
PROPOSE THE HEAD OF PERCENT
FUNDING BUT IN ORDER TO SPREAD
THE DOLLARS WE PUT IN CO FUNDING
OF 35% SO WE COULD HIT MORE
CAMPUSES YOU STILL LIKE 100%
FUNDING. IT CERTAINLY MAKES IT
EASY EASIER FOR CAMPUS PROCEED.
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BACARDI- GIVEN
THE ORIGINAL PROMISE OF REALLY
FOCUSING ON AFFORDABILITY THE-
THE PROPOSAL INITIAL PROPOSAL OF
A 100% FUNDING WITH THE
COMMITMENT THAT DISTRICTS
DELIVER ON THE PROJECT PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE RENTS THAT REALLY
DELIVERS ON THAT COMMITMENT SO
TO YOUR QUESTION I REALLY DO
THINK THAT IT'S A BOTH AND SO
REMAINING WITH THE COMMITMENT OF
PROVIDING A 100% FUNDING FOR
THREE ROUNDS OF GRANTS AND IF
NEW ONE TIME DOLLARS ARE
AVAILABLE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
UNDER SURPLUS CONDITIONS OR
OTHER- INVESTING IN NEW PROJECTS
THAT ARE SHOVEL READY AND CAN
MOVE FORWARD. BUT ALSO HAVING AN
AND- ELEMENT TO YOUR PROPOSAL
WHERE AS YOU'RE LOOKING LONG
TERM AT THIS SEVENTY FIVE OTHER
PLANNING GRANTS ARE COMING
FORWARD CONSIDERING WHAT OPTIONS
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM SUCH AS AT
LOW TO NO COSTS INTEREST LOANS
SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE THE STATE
COULD HAVE A LONG TERM STRATEGY
AS WELL TO ADDRESSING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD PREFER TO FIND
FEWER PROJECTS WITH GREATER
SUBSIDY TEND TO SPREAD THE
FUNDING ACROSS MORE PROJECTS.
BECAUSE STOCK WAY OF WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE A-
GREATER NUMBER OF LOW COST UNITS
WITHIN THE HOUSING. ARE PROJECTS
BEING PROPOSED. AT THE EXISTING
STATUTE REQUIRES THAT DEAL- LOW
INCOME RENTAL UNITS WITH IN
THOSE HOUSING PROJECTS BE
OFFERED AT 15% OF HALF OF THE
MEDIAN INCOME OF FOR THAT AREA.
WHERE TO CAMPUS IS LOCATED AND
THAT MEANS THAT THE RENTAL RATES
FOR THOSE ROOMS ARE FORCED TO BE
QUITE LOW- UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DID PUT FORWARD THREE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE NO- FINANCIAL
VIABILITY IF THEY DO NOT
RECEIVE. THE FULL STATE GRANT
THAT WAS BEING REQUESTED SO WE
ARE REQUESTING- GREATER FUNDING
FOR FUTURE PROJECTS THANK YOU.
AND WHAT WOULD THE L. A. L. YOUR
MOVE YOUR HAND OVER THERE SO I
JUST TO SHARPEN THAT POINT ON
THAT YOU MADE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY- THE STATUE DID NOT SET
FORTH SPECIFIC GUIDELINES ON
FUND MATCHING. AND SO ALL THE
APPLICATIONS VERY QUITE A BIT IN
TERMS OF WHETHER WAS A 100%
STATE FUNDING OR A MIX OF STATE
FUNDING AND ON STATE FUNDING CSU
TOOK A PRETTY BLANKET APPROACH
OF DOING 65% STATE 35% NONSTATE.
BROTHER SEGMENTS THE CAMPUS IS
VERY QUITE A BIT- IF THAT IS OF
INTEREST TO YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPREAD FUNDING OVER MORE
PROJECTS TO PROTECT. POTENTIALLY
COVER MORE PROJECTS MORE
CAMPUSES. A ONE STATUTORY CHANGE
YOU COULD CONSIDER IS- SETTING
FORTH SPECIFIC FUND MATCHING
GUIDELINES LIKE. 20% OR 30% OF
THE COST WOULD BE. COVERED
THROUGH NON STATE FUNDS SO THAT
THAT IS AN OPTION TO THE
LEGISLATURE IF IT IF IT DID WANT
TO SPREAD. SPREAD MORE FUNDS
OVER MORE PROJECTS. FOR OKAY.
QUESTIONS MISTREATING. SO JUST
JUST A SECOND A POINT FOR ONE
SECOND I THINK- IT SEEMS THAT
THE SEGMENTS WOULD LIKE TO. HAVE
THE GREATER SUBSIDY OR THE TWO
SEGMENTS LIKE THAT THE GREATER
SUBSEA JUST BECAUSE THEN HAS
GREATER CERTAINTY OF THE PROJECT
BEING COMPLETED VERSES- IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A POT OF MONEY TO ADD
TO THAT PROJECT THEN YOU HAVE TO
GO OUT AND SEARCH FOR THAT MONEY
RIGHT SO I THINK- ONE ME WHAT WE
COULD DO IS. THAT THE SEGMENTS
DECIDE SAY CSU'S DECIDED HEY
THEY HAD THEY WERE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE 35% THEY CAN LEVERAGE
THAT OTHER MONEY OTHERS TWO
SEGMENTS DECIDED NOT TO RESIGN.
FEREBEE COMFORT CHARACTERIZATION
OF WHAT THE WHAT WAS SAID. SINGH
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT GOOD- SO-
REGARDING JUST SORT OF- GOOD
JUST GOING TO YOU SEE FOR ONE
QUICK SECOND SO YOU UCLA- WAS
ABLE TO ANNOUNCE THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE SCHOOL'S
HISTORY THEY ARE ABLE TO OFFER-
ENTERING FRESHMEN FOUR YEARS OF
HOUSING WHICH I THINK WAS A
FAIRLY FAIRLY HISTORIC- STEP IN
SO- COULD YOU GIVE US AN IDEA OF
HOW THEY WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
THAT ESPECIALLY IN AN AREA THAT
IS VERY. URBAN VERY INFILL IS
NOT MERCED IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO BUILD IN THE WESTERN PART OF
LOS ANGELES COULD YOU BE TO WALK
US THROUGH HOW THEY'RE ABLE TO
KIND OF ACHIEVE THAT GOAL MAYBE
WHY WHY OTHER UC'S WEREN'T ABLE
TO. OF THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SIR- UCLA WAS ABLE TO
CONSTRUCT FIVE THOUSAND
DORMITORY BEDS A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER FROMTHE CAMPUS IN THE
HILLS THAT WERE- STILL ON OCT
UNOCCUPIED LAND- AND UCLA HAS-
USED IN MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES
HAVE USED A LOT OF P. THREE
PROJECTS. WHICH- MEAN THAT THE
CAMPUS OWNS THE LAND- A
DEVELOPER BUILDS THE BUILDING
AND THE DEVELOPERS COLLECTING
THE RENTAL PAYMENTS FROM THE
STUDENTS IN ORDER TO PAY
THEMSELVES BACK FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION- P. THREE
DORMITORIES SOMETIMES MAY HAVE
SLIGHTLY HIGHER RENTS THE NON P.
THREE DORMITORIES- NOT ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES HAVE HAD THE-
OPPORTUNITY TO FIND LAND THAT
IS. UNOCCUPIED NEAR CAMPUS AND-
D. DUST ABOLITION OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS DOES TAKE TIME TO
GET THAT P. THREE FINANCING GOT
IT IN WITHIN WITH P. THREES- AND
I GUESS FOR THE TRANSLATION
PREVIOUS PREVIOUS OUR PRIVATE
PRIVATE DEVELOPERS YES PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP RIGHT NOW
CORRECT THANK YOU- IN SO FOR.
UCLA IN PARTICULAR FOR THOSE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS- THE
RENTS WILL PROBABLY BE CLOSER TO
MARKET THAN THEY WOULD IF IT WAS
A STATE COMPLETELY STATE
SUBSIDIZED- PROPERTY WHICH I
IMAGINE WOULD HAVE LOWER RENTS.
I DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF ME WHAT
THE RENT IS FOR THOSE
DORMITORIES I CAN GET THAT FOR
YOU BUT I DO KNOW THAT ALL OUR
CAMPUSES WE STRIVE TO HAVE.
RENTS EITHER ACT MARKET OR BELOW
MARKET UP 220% BELOW MARKET.
GODDESS OF STUDENTS WERE
DIRECTED SAY TO THOSE P. THREE.
PROPERTIES THEY WOULD
NECESSARILY FEEL A DIFFERENCE
THAN. THE OTHER UCLA HOUSING
UNITS. THAT'S CORRECT OKAY- AND
YOU JUST GO INTO LA- REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE POINTS THAT
YOU RAISED ON I MEAN THERE'S A
COUPLE. COUPLE ISSUES. PART PART
OF THIS HOUSING PART OF MONEY
THAT- THE ASSEMBLY ADVOCATED FOR
WHICH WE WERE NOT ABLE TO. GET
INTO THE AGREEMENT WAS NOT ONLY
WITH HIS HOUSING MONEY. BUT THIS
COULD BE USED FOR CAMPUS
EXPANSION- AS AS WE SAW FROM
THIS UC BERKELEY CASE- WE'VE
BEEN ASKING ALL THE SEGMENTS OFF
ALL THREE SEGMENTS TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT TO INCREASE CAPACITY
WE HAVE A TWO MILLION. DEGREE
SHORTFALL IN IT'S IMPORTANT AT
ALL THREE. SEGMENTS INCREASED
CAPACITY WELL HOUSING IS A VERY
CRITICAL PIECE OF THAT
OBVIOUSLY. YOU CAN'T INCREASE
CAPACITY IF YOU DON'T MORE
CLASSROOMS MORE FACULTY MORE.
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SO I
THINK. THAT'S THE PART THAT I
THINK IS ALSO. A POTENTIALLY
MISSING HERE SO I DON'T KNOW IF
EL AL HAS. DONE ANY ANALYSIS OR
THOUGHTS- I DO I DO- I DO FEEL
THE- ISSUES THAT L. A. REYES AS
CRY TO. MORE YOU TO FULLY
CONSIDER AROUND- THE ABILITY TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT CAPACITY- IF
THE HOUSING SUPPLY CONSTRAINTS
IN A PARTICULAR COMMUNITY-
OBVIOUSLY IF HOUSING IS ALREADY
CHEAPER PLENTIFUL IN A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY- I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S MAYBE THE BEST
PLACE TO BUILD MORE. MORE
HOUSING- ALTHOUGH- ALTHOUGH FOR
SOME YOU KNOW HARDER TO REACH
SPECIALLY FOR COMMUNICABLE JUST
HARDER TO REACH REGIONS- WHERE
YOU KNOW A COMMUTE MAY BE A TWO
HOUR COMMUTE NOT A TWENTY MINUTE
COMMUTE. OBVIOUSLY WE DO HAVE TO
FACTOR THAT IN SO THAT THAT
COULD BE ANOTHER FACTOR- I DON'T
BELIEVE SHOVEL READY WAS SORT OF
A FACTOR. IS THAT MY RIGHT EXACT
COUNT OKAY NOT NOT A THANK YOU.
AND THEN ALSO- HELPING ALONG
WITH THE WITH THE WITH THE ROMA
CAPACITY INCREASES ALSO TO SORT
OF. ABILITY TO DO THE CAMPUS
EXPANSION SO JUST GOING TO-
FINANCE- WERE. YOU KNOW IS
ESERVER HERE GOING INTO THIS
SORT OF NEXT VERSION I THINK
WITH ANY WITH ANY FIRST YEAR WE
LEARNED A LOT WE SEE A LOT. YOU
KNOW AND I THINK IT'S GREAT I'M
I'M REALLY HAPPY THAT THIS GOT.
ALSO GOT OFF THE GROUND. WE'RE
SEEING THEIR PROJECTS WE'RE
SEEING A HUGE DEMAND FOR
PROJECTS BUT JUST GOING TO
FINANCE FOR SECOND. WHAT WHAT
ABOUT YOU KNOW FURTHER
CONSIDERING SOME OF THESE.
FACTORS AND ALSO AGAIN ONE OF
THE CRITIQUES OF LA- WAS THAT
THE FACTORS WEREN'T- SORT OF
WIDELY PUBLICIZED BEFORE THE-
APPLICATIONS WERE IN WHICH I
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S WE'RE TRYING
TO BE FAST. SO I'M NOT THAT'S
NOT A- CRITIQUE IS JUST A IT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL PRIORITIZE
RE PRIORITIZE SPEED THIS YEAR
WHICH I THINK IS IMPORTANT. I
GIVE YOUR HOUSE A SHORT BUT WHAT
WHAT ABOUT IRAN THE CAPACITY.
HOUSING SUPPLY CONSTRAINTS AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW PRIORITIZING
PROJECTS THAT ARE READY READY TO
GO. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT-
QUESTION. I CHAIR TANG- SO WE'VE
FIRST NOTE THAT- OUR REVIEW OF
THESE APPLICATIONS WAS. REALLY
BASED IN IN THE STATUTE- AND
NAMELY YOU KNOW ONE OF THAT. THE
TO BEING- CONSTRUCTION COSTS PER
BED WHICH IS REALLY AN
EFFICIENCY METRICS- AND THEN RAN
TO WHICH WAS. REALLY THE KEEP
COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM RIGHT
IS STUDENT AFFORDABILITY- AND IN
TERMS OF THE OP OPTIONS THAT
YOU'VE PLAYED. SOME OF THEM
BEING- YOU KNOW. THINGS NOTED IN
STATUTE YET YUP YEAH NOT
REQUIRED IN TERMS OF OUR OUR
EVALUATION- IT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING- SO THE THINGS THAT WE
ARE ARE IN STATURE THAT WE COULD
HAVE CONSIDERED. ABOLITION
STATUTE WE DIDN'T TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT AT THIS TIME- BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
. I WOULD JUST CURIOUS WHAT L.
A- THOUGHT ABOUT- FURTHER
EXPANDING THE CRITERION TO THOSE
AREAS AS WELL AS WITH THE
SEGMENTS MIGHT. THINK ABOUT THAT
- YES SO. A STATUTE AS AS A
FINANCE NOTED ACTUALLY HAD SEVEN
SPECIFIC FACTORS THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED. AND THEY LARGELY
ALIGNED WITH A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU RAISED AROUND IN AS A
SHOVEL READY. ENROLLMENT
CAPACITY- IT ALSO INCLUDES
OPTIONS LIKE CONSIDERING THE
SHARE OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THAT ARE IMPACTED AT A
PARTICULAR CAMPUS. THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERED JUST
ONE OF THESE FACTORS WHICH WAS
ON WHETHER OR NOT THE PROJECT
WAS ANDERSON METAL AND GIVE.
HIGH PRIORITY TO THAT ANY
INTERSEGMENT A PROJECT THAT WAS
ELIGIBLE IMMEDIATELY GOT RANKS
NUMBER ONE. I DIDN'T EXPLICITLY
CONSIDER THESE OTHER FACTORS AND
SO- YOU KNOW IF THESE ARE
FACTORS THAT ARE OF PRIORITY TO
LEGISLATURE IT COULD CONSIDER.
INCORPORATING THEM INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH OR
COULD IT COULD DO IT IN LIEU
ONCE SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S METHODOLOGY. I
GET A TON OF DEPENDS ON- WHICH
OF THESE SORT OF METRICS ARE OF
PARTY THE LEGISLATURE IN WHICH
SORT OF A LANGUAGE IN SCHOOLS. I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
STAFF ON EXPORT OTHER OPTIONS IN
THE IN THE COMING MONTHS- COULD
NOT GO BACK TO FINANCE WITHIN
THE OTHER. THEIR OTHER FACTORS
IN. THE STATUE WAS A REASON THAT
THOSE WERE NOT PART OF THE-
ANALYSIS OF THE CURRENT. YEAH I
THINK FOR US IT WAS AGAIN LIKE
GOING BACK TO THE STATUTE I
THINK THAT WAS THE MAIN CONCERN
AND THEN ADDITIONALLY WE WHAT WE
NEEDED TO EVALUATE SOMETHING
THAT WAS CONSISTENT ACROSS. ALL
APPLICATIONS AND SO CONSTRUCTION
COSTS PER BED WAS IN A- YOU KNOW
THE SAME METRIC RIGHT DOLLAR U.
S. DOLLAR TO BED. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY THE RENT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE REQUIRED VERY
SPECIFICALLY IN STATURE AND SO
WE WERE ABLE TO GAUGE WHAT THEY
ARE. THEIR MAXIMUM COST WAS ABLE
TO BE AND THEN WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THAT COST- THEY REACH TO THAT
WAS A CONSISTENT MEASURE ACROSS
ALL APPLICATIONS. REBECCA'S
CONSTRUCTION COSTS- IS GOING TO
VARY. WIDELY ACROSS THE STATE I
MEAN CONSTRUCTION COSTA SAN
FRANCISCO VERSUS. CONSTRUCTION
COSTS IN CHESTER ARE. YOU KNOW
THE MUCH WILL BE A TWO STATES
SITES I THINK I THINK. WE WANT
WE WANT TO USE THE MONEY
EFFICIENTLY I TOLD WE CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT. HAVING FINANCIAL
METRICS BUT I DO. BELIEVE THAT
WE HAVE TO. LOOK AT SOME IS
OTHER FACTORS AS WELL- IN AND
HAVING SAID THAT OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE PLENTY OF GOOD PROJECTS I
DON'T THINK I WILL YOU KNOW AND
JUST JUST TAKING A SCAN OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT THE- U. S. LOOKS
LIKE MANY OF THESE MOST THESE
PROJECTS ARE VERY GOOD SO IT'S
NOT. IT'S NOT A REALLY MATTER IF
IT'S MEAN TO ME IT'S REALLY
MATTER FOUGHT WHEN AND HOW HOW
DO WE HOW DO WE HELP SUPPORT.
GETTING THESE PROGRAMS OFF THE
GROUND. I DON'T KNOW IF THE
SEGMENTS HAD ANY. ANY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE CRITERION. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY. CHIANG I THINK CSU IF
WE HAD KNOWN THAT. ONE OF THE
CRITERIA WOULD BE HOW FAR BELOW
THE 30% 250% WE COULD HAVE
FASHIONED. OUR USE OF THE 30%
DIFFERENTLY. AND SWUNG THAT
METRIC. YEAH I THOUGHT WE
THOUGHT THE CONSTRUCTION START
DATE WAS ONE OF THE KEY DRIVERS
BASED ON THE IMMEDIACY AND THE
PRIORITY. SO THAT WAS ONE OF OUR
FACTORS AND CUTTING UP WHICH
PROJECTS. THANK YOU. I'LL JUST
ADD A COUPLE OF KEY POINTS I
THINK THERE ARE SOME DEFINITE
OPPORTUNITY COSTS THAT ARE.
REALLY WORTH CONSIDERING SOME OF
WHICH HAVE ALREADY BEEN INCLUDED
WHICH IS- IF THE CONCERN IS HOW
QUICKLY THE STATE CAN DELIVER ON
AFFORDABLE PROJECTS REALLY
LOOKING AT. THE ABILITY OF A OF
A PROJECT TO DELIVER IS KEY-
BOTH IN THEIR CONSTRUCTION
TIMELINE- AND IN THE COMMITMENT-
THE OTHER- CONSIDERATIONS
LOOKING DOWN THE LINE ARE- SOME
OF THE COMMUNITY FACTORS OF WHO
IS SERVED. AND THEY COST OF
RENTS IN THAT REGION COMPARED
TO- THE RENT THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THESE PROJECTS OF THOSE ARE SOME
VIABLE ONES. THAT ALSO ARE. TO
THE AFFORDABILITY VALUES OF THIS
PROGRAM. AND THOSE WERE
EXCELLENT COMMENTS ALL JUST ADD
THAT- FIRST UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S OVERSUBSCRIBED WITH
ALL THE PROJECTS WE ALREADY PUT
FORWARD. I DO THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE WORTHWHILE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO COMPARE OF
REGIONAL CONSTRUCTION COSTS
RATHER THAN ALL THE CONSTRUCTION
COST. OF ALL THE PROJECTS
AGAINST EACH OTHER BECAUSE COSTS
CAN VARY SO GREATLY ACROSS THE
STATE AND ALSO GIVEN- DIRECTION
OF INFLATION RIGHT NOW LOOKING
AT THE ABILITY OF THE CAMPUS TO
PROVIDE. NON STATE FUNDING FOR
CONTINGENCY COSTS AND ALSO
CONSTRUCTION START DATE MAY BE
BENEFICIAL. I DON'T KNOW THE
SEGMENTS HAD ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT-
I KNOW WHAT AREA WE DIDN'T COVER
WAS AROUND- PAYING FOR BUILDINGS
TO GREATER EXPAND OUR CAPACITY
AS AS AS THE CAMPUSES ARE
LOOKING AT CLASSROOM SPACE AND
BUILDING I DON'T KNOW IF THE
SEGMENT ANY COMMENTS ABOUT. THE
NEED FOR OUR CAPITAL MONEY TO
INCREASE CAPACITY OF CLASSROOMS
AND LABS SIX THAT ARE YOU KNOW
ALL ABOUT ALL THE ALL THE
EDUCATIONAL- THE BUILDINGS THAT
ARE NEEDED. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS A FIVE YEAR
FINANCING PLAN CAPITAL FINANCING
PLAN THAT CONTAINS OVER EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN POTENTIAL OF
ACADEMIC CONSTRUCTION. PROJECTS
TO ACCOMMODATE FUTURE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH WE DO WANT TO GROW BY.
TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS OR MORE
OVER THE NEXT- FIVE YEARS AND-
TO ACCOMMODATE THAT GROWTH WE
WILL BE NEEDING NEW CLASSROOM
SPACE. THANK YOU. SAYS CSU CUT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY ALSO
HAS A FIVE YEAR PLAN IN A
PRIORITY LIST THAT HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES IN A NUMBER OF THE
PROJECTS ARE ARE STEM RELATED
PROJECTS AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST.
SO THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE A
NEED THAT WE'VE ADVOCATED FOR A
LONG TIME ALONG WITH ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT WE HAVE GOT A NINE HUNDRED
MILLION STILL OUTSTANDING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR REQUEST. THANK YOU
. I THINK SIMILARLY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGES ARE
CAPITAL OFF OUR FIVE YEAR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PLAN IS FORTY
TWO- BILLION- BUT ONE KEY FOCUS
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. REALLY
BEEN MODERNIZATION. AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ACROSS OUR SYSTEM
THAT'S A KEY FOCUS. I WILL SHARE
THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL WITHIN
THE REGULATORY ROUND WE ARE
LOOKING AT- THE ABILITY OF.
THESE NEW HOUSING FACILITIES TO
INTEGRATE. CLASSROOM AND STUDENT
SUPPORT SPACES WITHIN THEM. SO
THAT STUDENTS HAVE GREATER
PROXIMITY- HAVE THAT AGAIN
DIRECT CONNECTION TO STUDENT
SUCCESS WHICH IS A KEY GOAL OF
THIS PROGRAM. GREAT THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU ON THE SAME TOPIC
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MISTER MEDINA
AND THEN MISTER O'DONNELL SO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WANT TO
JUST KIND OF MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTAND PAGE FOUR AND FIVE
PAGE PAGE FOR ARE THE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE. BEEN APPROVED ON THE
AGENDA. YES THEY HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
YEAH AS APPROVED. RIGHT AND THEN
PAGE FIVE. ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE
. THOSE ARE APPLICANTS KNOW THE
ESERVER PLANNING GRANTS THAT WE
HAVE PROPOSAL LEGISLATURE YES
OKAY WELL I JUST WANTED TO UP ON
THE CHAIR ABOUT THE CHILDREN
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE ONE OF THE
CHILDREN WHO DIDN'T GET A
PRESENT. IN AND LOOKING AT. AT
THE EIGHT PROJECTS- ON THE LIST
THAT ARE FUNDED. RIGHT I DO NOT
SEE ANYTHING- IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. AND AS A CHILD DOESN'T
GET A PRESIDENT AND DOESN'T
ALWAYS OFTEN DOESN'T GET A
PRESENT I JUST THINK THAT
THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO AND I'M
GLAD THAT OUR MAJORITY LEADER
JUST CAME IN SO LET ME REPEAT
AGAIN FOR MAJORITY LEADER-
LOOKING AT THE LIST OF PROJECTS
THAT ARE FUNDED. OF THE EIGHT
THERE IS NOT IN THERE FOR THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND I JUST- STATED
THAT I FEEL LIKE THAT CHILD THAT
ARE SHARED IS TALKING ABOUT WHO
DOESN'T GET A PRESENT WE ARE
OFTEN. THE CHILD GETS OVERLOOKED
SO I HOPE THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING MORE AS WE HAD THE
MEETINGS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS PERTAINING TO
HOUSING. IT IS- ISSUE AS ARE WE
ALL KNOW THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
WHEREVER WHETHER WE WERE. IN THE
FRESNO OR- STOCKTON FOR
RIVERSIDE OR SAN BERNARDINO
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS IS AN
ISSUE. AND I'D- THINK THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE FOR THE INLAND
EMPIRE THANK. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL THE RESEARCHER- AND I
JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
HERE MY COLLEAGUE IN SACRAMENTO
WHO HAVE PUSHED FOR STUDENT
HOUSING AND MONEY TO SUPPORT
STUDENT HOUSING. ON ALL SEGMENTS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND THEY'VE
DONE A LOT OF HARD WORK SO THE
FACT THAT WE'RE HERE TODAY IS TO
ACTUALLY A LOT OF THEIR THEIR
HARD WORK. O THIS ACTUALLY GOOD
THING BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT HOW
WE GET IT DONE I JUST HOPE WE
CAN GET MONEY THERE'S MONEY OUT
THERE WILL BE MORE YES- BUT THE
NEED HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED NOW
RESPONDING- SO THAT THAT'S A
GOOD THING. AND JUST TO CLARIFY
MAYBE THIS QUESTIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN PAGE
FOR THOSE PROJECTS ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE THOSE A 100% FINANCED
ALL OF THOSE PROJECTS NOW
THEY'RE NOT OKAY- AND THEN THE
PLANNING GRANTS. LANDERS THAT.
AND I JUST WANNA GO TO THE
TRADITIONAL METHOD MAYBE I'LL
TAKE LONG BEACH STATE BECAUSE
THAT'S THE PLACE I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH. AS ONE UNDERSTAND
THIS- DORM ROOMS ARE AMONG THE
STATE AND TRADITIONALLY THEY'VE
BEEN BUILT. I ASSUME THAT.
SOMEONE WOULD FLOAT A BOND I
ASSUME. AND IT WE CREATE KIND OF
AN ENTERPRISE FUND AN AGENCY
WITHIN AN AGENCY IF YOU WILL.
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
OF STUDENT HOUSING AND THEY
WOULD PAY THE BONDS. OFF THROUGH
THE FEES THAT STUDENTS PAY TO
LIVE THERE IS THAT ACCURATE. YES
MEMBERS DONNA WE HAVE A SYSTEM
WIDE REVENUE BONDS IT'S A PLEDGE
OF SELF SUPPORT AND GENERAL FUND
THAT WE USE FOR STUDENT HOUSING
STUDENT UNIONS PARKING ACADEMIC
BUILDINGS. HOW DO YOU USE P.
THREES AT ALL. OR HAVE YOU HAVE
WE HAVE USED P. THREES WE HAVE A
RECENT ONE THAT JUST CAME UP THE
SAN FRANCISCO. FOR THE STUDENT
HOUSING YES THAT'S CORRECT
FORTUNATELY- OKAY- WHAT WHAT
ABOUT OF THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
OF ARE YOU CONTEMPLATING ANY
TYPE OF P. THREES ARE. AFTER THE
NEW. SO THEY PER- SEVENTY FIVE
PLANNING SOME OF THESE DO HAVE
PROPOSED P. THREES WE HAVE A
COUPLE THAT ARE- EXPLORING
SOMETHING CALLED P. FOUR WHICH
IS A PUBLIC PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP SO IT OFTEN INCLUDES
EITHER THEIR COUNTY OR THEIR
CITY ALSO SUPPORTING THE
PROJECTS THAT WE DO HAVE SOME OF
THOSE AND WITHIN THE ELIGIBLE
GRANTS- ONE OF THESE PROJECTS-
IS PROPOSED AS- A P. THREE. SO
THIS CALL NEXT QUESTIONS READY.
UNDER THE P. THREE MODEL WITH
THAT WOULD WOULD IT BE PRIVATELY
OPERATED TO. I CAN SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
MODELS THAT WE'VE SEEN HERE IN
THESE APPLICATIONS IS THAT
THEY'RE OFTEN- THERE TWO
APPROACHES ONE IS THAT THEY HELP
IN TERMS OF THE FINANCING GET
THE- PROJECT OFF THE GROUND- FOR
THIS PROJECT IT STARTED WELL
BEFORE. THE STUDENT HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM FROM THE STATE SO
THEY NEEDED THAT IN ORDER TO GET
OFF THE GROUND SINCE THEY DON'T
HAVE RESOURCES LOCALLY- OTHER
MODELS THAT ALREADY EXISTS THAT
ARE BUILT- AND OFFERED AT OUR
CAMPUSES ONE IN ORANGE COUNTY-
THEY WORK WITH THE P. THREE TO
PROVIDE MAINTENANCE TO THE
SUPPORT OF THE FACILITIES-
BECAUSE THEY- HAVE- ON CAMPUS.
OR AT STAFFING THE TRADITIONAL
P. THREE MODEL ANOTHER CORRECT
OKAY. GREAT ALL RIGHT I THINK
THAT IS MY SUMS UP MY QUESTION
ABOUT AGAIN I HOPE THAT AND I
AND I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING I KNOW
THAT BUT I HOPE WE LOOK
ALTERNATIVE MODELS JUST OTHER
THAN THE BOND RATHER IT OTHER
THAN A 100% FINANCING QUITE
FRANKLY ON HOW TO GET- THESE-
HOUSING. UNITS BUILT SO THANK
YOU. I HAD A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION ON YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT WHICH PROJECTS ARE A 100%
STATE FUNDED AND WHICH ARE A MIX
SO ABOUT FOUR OF THE EIGHT
PROJECTS ARE I THOUGHT ABOUT FOR
THE PROJECTS ARE A MIX OF STATE
AND NON STATE FUNDED IN THE
OTHER FOUR ARE A 100% STATE
FUNDED. SO IT'S A MIX AND WITHIN
THAT EIGHT THAT THAT ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSTRUCTION. THANK
YOU. I JUST I KNOW I THINK THIS.
QUESTION JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP-
WE'RE VERY LEERY TO THAT.
BECAUSE THAT JUST MEANS MORE
THAN LIKELY IT'S- NEW YORK WALL
STREET INVESTMENT COMPANIES
MAKING MONEY OFF THE PROJECT. BY
SQUEEZING COMMUNICABLE STUDENTS
WHO BY DEFINITION AS YOU STATED
EARLIER. ARE THE POOREST AMONG
THANK THE STUDENTS. AND SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A BUILT IN
INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO INCREASE
RENT. AND AND MAKE MONEY OFF THE
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE A LOT OF MY
IN THE FIRST PLACE WHICH IS WHY
FOR THE UC AND CSU WE LIKE THE
MODEL WHERE THEY OWNED AND
OPERATED BECAUSE THEN IT'S THE
UNIVERSITY. THEY'RE TRYING TO
COVER THEIR COSTS AND KEEP COSTS
DOWN SO I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMUNICATORS DON'T HAVE THE
EXPERTISE. TO DO THIS SO YOU
NEED AN OUTSIDE PARTNER BUT THE
FLIP SIDE IS YOU KNOW YEAR UP
HERE ON A REGULAR BASIS TALKING
ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU NEED HELP FOR
YOUR STUDENTS WHO ARE SOMETIMES
IN DIRE STRAITS. AND THIS MODEL
MAY NOT NECESSARILY. HELP THE
SAME STUDENTS RATE PROTECTING TO
MISTER CARAVAN HELP YEAH I'M I'M
GONNA CHALLENGE THAT A BIT I'M
NOT GONNA SAY YOU'RE COMPLETELY
WRONG NOR ARE YOU COMPLETELY
CORRECT. I THINK IF DONE
CORRECTLY IF WRITTEN CORRECTLY
YES GAVE SAFEGUARDS ARE PUT IN A
P. THREE CAN BE THE RIGHT TOOL
IT ISN'T ALWAYS THE RIGHT TOOL
FOR SURE. BUT EVEN BOND AS A
MECHANISM OF WALL STREET CORRECT
CAN I GET YOUR POINT THAT IT
REALLY NEEDS TO WATCH WE JUST
CAN'T TURN A PIECE OF PUBLIC
LAND. OVER TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND EXPECT THEM TO DO RIGHT BY
THE STUDENTS THERE NEEDS TO BE
AND WHEN THESE CONTRACTS ARE
WRITTEN WHICH ARE HIGHLY
TECHNICAL. THERE NEEDS TO BE
SIGNIFICANT. SAFEGUARDS AND MP
THREES ARE NOT A PANACEA THEY'RE
NOT IN OF THE HOLY GRAIL BUT I
THINK THEY ARE TOOL IN SOME
PLACES AT CERTAIN TIMES I. TO
THIS IS BUT AGAIN ALWAYS. BUT
AGAIN GOT TO BE DONE CORRECTLY
IT IS CAN'T TURN IT OVER A LOT
OF TIME IN THE P. THREE
ENVIRONMENT. YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THEM THEY HAND SOMETHING
OVER TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
WHAT HAPPENS IS EXACTLY. WHAT
YOU STATED BUT AGAIN IF DONE
CORRECTLY THEY CAN BE A TOOL TO-
TO- TO SOLVE A PROBLEM. YEAH
YEAH AND THEN THAT WE ARE WE
HAVE THAT IN PLACE FOR THE UC
AND CSU AND ONE KIND OF NEW ONES
THERE AND MISTER JOHN YOU'RE
CORRECT AS YOU CAN HAVE THAT P.
THREE BILL DEBT LIKE SANTA SACKS
STATED AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO
THE UNIVERSITY TO OWN OPERATE
AND THEREFORE THEY WILL KEEP
THAT RENTS DOWN SO- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S SOMETHING KIND
THE MIDDLE GROUND HERE TOO. I
GUESS THE BIG PICTURE HERE IS
THAT WE'RE OPENING A CAN OF
WORMS ON THIS THIS HOUSING THING
AND SELLS LIKE WHAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER THIS WHERE WE'RE
SAYING HEY WE SHOULD GET IN THE
BUSINESS OF HELPING- FOCUS ON
HOUSING WE HAVE. YOU KNOW WHY WE
HAVE A MASSIVE SURPLUS WE HAVE.
LIMITED RESOURCES WE CAN'T
UNLIMITED. DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
WANT TO. ACCOMPLISH HERE SO HOW
DO WE- MAXIMIZE. AND PICK AS
MANY. WINNERS AS MR MEDINA
TALKED ABOUT HIS COMMUTE THERE
AND RIVERSIDE- MISTER DOCTOR
CHOI DID YOU HAVE YOUR HAND UP
TO GO HEAD. I WAS WONDERING- IF
FOR YOU HAVE DEVELOPED ANY PLAN
ONCE A BUILDING IS IT IN PLACE
ON. HOW SINCE WE HAVE TALK- WHAT
THE- AFFORDABLE. THE CHILDREN
HOUSING- DO YOU HAVE A PLAN AT
THIS TIME- WHAT WILL BE PROPER
WAY OF- ARE CHARGING. THE
STUDENTS- OF WAS A LIVING IN THE
WILL IT BE INCOME BASED A SCALE
- AND HOW YOU GONNA PROVE IT-
WAS IT WHAT WOULD IT BE. TAX
RETURNS- AND THEN ALSO- YOU DO
HAVE- SUBSTATION PERCENTAGE OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE FROM ALL OVER
SEIZE. DAY AND- OUT OF STATE AS
WELL. WILL THEY QUALIFY EQUALITY
OR WILL IT BE A DIFFERENT PLAN
TOTAL CHARGE THEM BECAUSE ALL
THE BUILDINGS SO WILL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY IF NOT 100% THOUGH
OR NOT PUBLICLY FUNDED UP BY
CALIFORNIANS. A THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA-
WE WILL HAVE THE DORMITORIES AT
RECEIVE ASSISTANCE FROM THE
STATE WILL HAVE TO RATES ONE FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND ONE
FOUR- NON LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
ONLY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
STUDENTS WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT LOW INCOME STUDENTS SUBSIDY
RATE UP WE WILL SELECT THEM
BASED ON THEIR FINANCIAL AID
PAPERWORK THAT THEY HAVE
SUBMITTED SO THE STUDENT DOES
HAVE TO APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID-
AND THEN IF THAT STUDENT IS
FOUND TO HAVE FINANCIAL NEED.
THERE WILL BE TOLD THERE IS- THE
AVAILABILITY OF ON CAMPUS
HOUSING AT A MUCH LOWER RATE FOR
THAT STUDENT- SO THAT THAT'S HOW
WE ARE CURRENTLY PLANNING ON
RUNNING THE PROGRAM DO YOU HAVE-
DEFINITION KNOW WHO ARE THE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS- WE HAVE NOT.
DETERMINED ADAM. POLICY YET IN
TERMS OF THE APPLICATION THAT
THESE DORMITORIES BUT WE DO
HAVE- MANY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
STUDENTS ON OUR CAMPUSES WHO-
HAVE LOW INCOME TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY HAVE WHAT'S CALLED A
ZERO EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION TOWARDS THEIR
EDUCATION. MEANING THAT THEY
HAVE EXTREMELY LIMITED FUNDS SO
WE WOULD LOOK TO TOP POOL OF
STUDENTS FIRST. OKAY I AND THEN
THE QUESTION IS THAT THE- I DO
KNOW THAT THOSE INCOME
CATEGORIES CHILDREN SO. TO MY
IMPRESSION THEY HAVE A ABUNDANCE
OF FINANCIAL AID TO PROGRAM
SELECT A CAL GRANT- AND UP POPS
OUT- GOVERNMENT THERE'S SOME
STAR- AS A SUBSIDY AND THEN ALSO
YOU HAVE OF. IS DIFFERENT KINDS-
BOOK IN TONER UNIVERSITY-
SCHOLARSHIP SO- I'M PLAY ENOUGH
TO PAY THEIR REGULAR. IN OTHER
CELL AFFORDING THEIR OWN HOUSING
. YOU'RE CORRECT WE CURRENTLY
OFFER SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL AID
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE STUDENT THEN HAS WHAT'S
CALLED- THE SELF HELP LEVEL
WHICH IS CURRENTLY SET IN
STATUTE AT JUST UNDER EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS LIKE. SEVEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
SOMETHING- IT'S SET IN STATUTE
AND THAT'S THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO STUDENT HAS TO COME UP WITH I
THROUGH THEIR OWN WORK OR LOANS-
SO WHILE WE DO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
FINANCIAL AID FOR OUR LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS THEY STILL DO
HAVE NEED OF WE WOULD NOT EXCEED
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE IN
THE AID TWENTY STUDENT WE CAN'T
WE CAN'T DO THAT BY FEDERAL LAW.
SO IF THE STUDENT LOOKS LIKE
THEY NO LONGER HAVE FINANCIAL
NEED- AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
GETTING TOO MUCH INSTITUTIONAL
AID WE WOULD THEN TAKE SOME OF
THAT INSTITUTIONAL AID AND GIVE
IT TO A LESS NEEDY STUDENT NOW
WHO WHO DID NOT HAVE A ZERO
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION SO
WE'LL USE OUR FINANCIAL AID
PROCESS TO DETERMINE WHO ARE D.
STUDENTS WHO HAVE. MADE OKAY
AMONG THOSE SO- AT THE KERN.
TIME UC SYSTEM- HOW MANY ARE-
DETERRENT DETERMINE TO BE LOW
INCOME- OVERALL THE SELF FIRST A
NUMBER ALL ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE NEED TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT NUMBER DID I HEAR SIX
HUNDRED SOMETHING- SANDERS SAYS
SECOND QUESTION WOULD BE. ARE AT
THIS TIME OF FOR THOSE SO WHO
ARE. IN NEED OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND NOT WITHOUT. THE
HELP OF THE- YOU SEE THIS IS.
UNIVERSITY IS- HELPFUL AND- THEY
ARE STRUGGLING. SO SYSTEM WIDE
WE KNOW THE AMOUNT OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE CONSIDERED LOW INCOME AT
THE MOMENT ABOUT- 40% OF OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE PELL GRANTS ARE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS STUDENTS
RECEIVE PELL GRANTS WHICH IS
USUALLY A METRIC USED FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S A VERY LOW INCOME
STATUS- ON OUR CAMPUSES-
ANYWHERE BETWEEN. A ONE THIRD TO
HALF OF STUDENTS WILL HAVE A
GREAT FINANCIAL NEED- THE TWO
PROJECTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING PROPOSED TO RISK FUNDING
WOULD PROVIDE A COMBINED- ABOUT
ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
BEDS SO IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO MEET
THE NEED FOR. LOW INCOME HOUSING
ON THOSE CAMPUSES BUT IT IS A
GOOD START. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOSE MEDINA THE CHAIR OF
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
IN THE RECOGNITION THAT THE
INLAND EMPIRE RECEIVED NO
CONSTRUCTION GRANTS. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I HOPE THAT- WILL
BE REVISITED AND WILL BE
CORRECTED OKAY COLLEGE PLANNING
GRANTS I THINK IS A GOOD THING
BUT WE WANT TO GO BEYOND THE
PLANNING AND WE WANT TO ACTUALLY
GET THE CONSTRUCTION DONE. A
SECOND THING IS THAT THE
CONVERSATION REGARDING THE P.
THREE- AGREEMENTS AND CONTRACTS-
ARE USING THAT AS A TOOL I THINK
ABSOLUTELY THE SAFEGUARDS- NEED
TO BE THERE- FINALLY IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. MONEY COMING IN
FROM THE STATE. WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO PERHAPS ITS POLICY
PERHAPS REGULATIONS WHATEVER IT
IS NEEDS TO BE DONE TO SAFEGUARD
THE STATE'S INVESTMENT AND THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THE OWNERSHIP.
AND WITH THE OPERATION OF THE
STUDENT HOUSING. THE WE RECKON
THAT TO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
P. THREES WERE TALKING ABOUT
SOMEBODY USINGTHEIR PERSONAL
FUNDS OR THE CORPORATE FUNDS TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE WITH FOR
THAT FOR THESE FOR THE HOUSING.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE THE OWNERSHIP THEY
HAVE A RIGHT OF RETURN THEY
DON'T HAVE THE OWNERSHIP AND I
THINK THAT SOMETHING. SHOULD BE
DONE SPECIFICALLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT THAT THOSE WHO
ARE PRIVATE INDUSTRY WHO DO
INVEST TO HELP IN THIS THAT IT'S
CLEAR THAT IT IS AN INVESTMENT
WITH THE RIGHT OF RETURN AS
OPPOSED TO AN INVESTMENT. WITH A
OF THE THOUGHT THAT OF OWNERSHIP
OF THE PROPERTY. AT THE OTHER
THING HAS TO DO SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE RENT AFFORDABILITY THE
WHOLE PURPOSE OF THE STUDENT
HOUSING IS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE HOUSING. AND IF WE
BILL THE HOUSING BUT IN THE END
OUR STUDENTS CAN'T AFFORD IT IT
IS NOT AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR
STUDENTS AND THAT IS IN THE END
THE MAIN REASON FOR THIS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT OUR STUDENTS WITH
THE GREATEST NEED- AND TO THOSE
OF THE STUDENTS THAT WE WANT TO
BE SURE THAT WE- PROVIDE HOUSING
FOR- IT THE- EARLIER TESTIMONY
BEFORE I STEPPED OUT. WE HEARD
FROM THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY THIS
STUDENTS WHO APPEARED TO BE
HOMELESS FOR PERIODS OF TIME
LIVING IN THEIR CARS AND- HAVING
TO SHARE. HOUSING WITH FIFTEEN
OTHER STUDENTS IN A HOUSE THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR SIX STUDENTS.
THESE ARE THE SORTS OF THINGS
THAT THIS THREE BILLION DOLLARS
WAS. OUR CHAIR WORKED VERY HARD-
IN IN MAKING SURE THAT WE ENDED
UP WITH SUCH A- SUCH AN
INVESTMENT FOR STUDENT HOUSING
AND YES IT IS OVER SUBSCRIBED
WITH FOR BILLION BEING- APPLIED
FOR. NONETHELESS IT IS FOR
STUDENTS IT ISN'T FOR PRIVATE
INDUSTRY TO MAKE. WE WANT THEM
TO MAKE A GOOD RATE OF RETURN
BUT WE DON'T WANT ANY OWNERSHIP
GOING OUTSIDE OF THE STATE IF IT
IS THE STATE'S INVESTMENT FOR
THE PURPOSE OF OUR STUDENTS. IF
I MAY MAKE A YES GO AHEAD-
MASHONALAND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
IN IN THE STATUTE IT DOES-
SPECIFICALLY INDICATE THAT- YOU
. AND CSU APPLICANTS ARE ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO USE A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP YOU KNOW AS PART OF
THE PROGRAM. YEAH JUST WANT TO
KEEP. YOU CAN YOU ADDRESS THIS
YOU SEE RIVERSIDE. ISSUE WELL
FIRST ALL. YOU'RE CORRECT THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO DID NOT
WIN INCLUDING MY OWN UNIVERSE
HERE AT SAC STATE. BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THIS WAS AROUND ONE
WE HAVE THREE ROUNDS OF THIS TWO
BILLION AND AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
PROPOSING ANOTHER FIVE BILLION
THROUGH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET SO.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE MANY-
PROJECTS AND GET FUNDED IT'S NOT
JUST WINNERS THE WINTERS ARE
STUDENTS WHO ARE GETTING
SQUEEZED OUT NOT JUST CURRENCY
BUT AS WE LOOK TO. DRUM EXPAND
COLLEGE ENROLLMENTS WE NEED TO
BUILD MORE HOUSING LOOKAS
HAPPENING AT UC BERKELEY SO WE
NEED THIS CRYSTAL CLEAR. BUT SO
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE OF YOU SEE
RIVERSIDE APPARENTLY THEY HAD A
REQUEST FOR FIFTY MILLION. AND
THEY- DIDN'T MEET THE- RENT.
COMPUTATION RELATED TO THEIR
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT WHAT IS
THE NAME AND ALL THAT MEANS YEAH
SO- IN STATURE. THE RENT TO BE
30% 250% OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME AND THEY PROPOSED A RENT
THAT WAS ABOVE THAT REQUIREMENT
. THAT WAS THAT STATUTES THE
BOSTON. YEAH SO THAT WAS THE
POLICY THAT WE SET FORTH IN THE
RULES FOR THE TWO BILLION FROM
LAST YEAR YES OKAY SO I GUESS A
FEW THINGS ONE. THEY CAN GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THAT PROJECT WE
COULD POTENTIALLY REEVALUATE
THAT THIRTY PERCENT- AND THEN
ALSO THE SECOND POT OF MONEY MAY
NOT HAVE THOSE EXACT. STRINGS IN
AND RESTRICTIONS ON THERE YEAH
AND WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THE RENT WOULD
MEET THEIR NEED FOR- TO MAINTAIN
THE FACILITY BECAUSE THAT WAS
ALSO A METRICS WE WOULD THAT WE
EVALUATED AS WELL. YEAH BUT ALSO
IT'S PROBABLY APPLES TO ORANGES
BECAUSE 30% OF WHAT IT IS AND
UCLA AND BERKELEY IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN 30% IN ALREADY
RIVERSIDE CELL. RIGHT I WOULD
NOTE FOR THAT FOR THE RENT
COMPETITION IN PARTICULAR IT'S
BASED BY COUNTY YES- YOU KNOW
THAT'S ONE WAY IN WHICH THE-
RENTAL RATES WERE REGIONALLY
ADJUSTED SO THE RENTAL RATE
RENTAL COMPUTATION FOR. UC
RIVERSIDE WAS BASED ON THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND MY VERSES
UCLA USING THE LOS ANGELES-
COUNTY. MI OKAY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. YES SIR I
COULD QUITE HEAR FROM THE SIDE
OF THE ROOM BUT USE SO OF COURSE
I AGREE ABOUT THE 30% OF HALF OF
AMI'S SO THEY CAN BE AFFORDABLE
BASED ON THE REGION BECAUSE
SOMETHING ABOUT. FACTORING IN
THE PRICE OF THE COST OF
MAINTENANCE OR SOMETHING THAT
WILL WHAT DID YOU SAY THAT. SO I
JUST SAID THAT- A PART OF THE
EVALUATION AS WELL WAS JUST TO
ENSURE THAT THE RAIN COULD. MEET
THEIR THEIR NEED TO MAINTAIN THE
FACILITY- BECAUSE IF THE RENT IS
BELOW THAT THAT NEED- YOU KNOW
WE WOULD JUST. HOPE THAT THEY
WOULD EXPLAIN HOW THEY WOULD
MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE. AND TO
AND THE CASE FOR UC RIVERSIDE
THEY WERE NOT UNABLE TO DO THAT-
NOW FOR THE CASE OF ROUTE UC
RIVERSIDE THEY JUST- THEIR
PROPOSED RENT THAT THEY PROVIDED
IN THEIR APPLICATION WAS ABOVE
THE REQUIRED AMOUNT. WITHIN
STATUTE. RIGHT SO I MEAN THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT AND I A LIME A
COMP EVERYONE ELSE SAID EVERY
GREAT POINT THAT I COULD'VE MADE
ALREADY BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY FOR THIS POPULATION OF
SPECIAL STUDENTS SPECIAL
CONCERNS. ALSO AS SOON IS PAYING
TO WORK RIGHT BEING A STUDENT
FULL TIME IS A JOB IN AND OF
ITSELF AND MAYBE THEY HAVE PART
TIME WORK TO SUPPLEMENT THAT.
BUT WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING ON
AFFORDABILITY AND- A HIGHER
SOME. IS BETTER- THERE IS OF
COURSE THIS POINT YOU RUN INTO
OF COURSE IF WE'RE BUILDING. AS
SUBSIDIZES POSSIBLE CAN THE
PROJECT CAN THE DEVELOPMENT
ITSELF BE SUSTAINED RIGHT AND
THAT'S A PROBLEM WE HAVE IN THE
LARGER CONTEXT. OF GOVERNMENT.
SPONSORED HOUSING THAT'S THE
LARGER PROBLEM WE HAVE IS LIKE
CAN IT BE SELF SUSTAINING. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING I HOPE THERE'S
SOME FACTOR NEW ONCE BECAUSE- OF
WHAT MAKES SENSE FOR THE P.
RIGHT FOR IT YOU KNOW WHAT
FIFTY. HALF OF START 30% OF HALF
OF AM I. IN RIVERS I COUNTY. IS
GREAT FOR THE FOR THE PERSON
BUT- THE FIXED COSTS OF
MAINTAINING A PLACE MAY NOT BE
QUITE. THE ROUNDED UP THAT WAY.
BECAUSE WITH THAT HAVE. 30% OF
HALF A MIND TO BE AREA WHERE I
REPRESENT OBVIOUSLY IS MUCH
GREATER AMOUNT AND CANS
SOMETIMES SUPPLEMENT THE CALL-
HIGH FIXED COSTS NOT ALWAYS.
THIS CAN DEPENDING ON THE
SITUATION- SO I THINK IT'S
ABOARD THE FACT. THINGS AND- YOU
KNOW I THINK I KNOW THAT SHARE
KIND OF BROUGHT UP SOME POINT
ABOUT. HOW YOU SPREAD THE WEALTH
AMONG THE CHILDREN. AND I HOPE
THAT WITH OUR ADDITIONAL ROUNDS
OF MONEY IN THE FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN. INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY
THAT WE CAN GET. TO- AS COMPLETE
SPEND FOR YOU ALL SPOTS BECAUSE
I KNOW WITH YOU THIS IS A J.
HOUSING. RIGHT IF THERE'S SO
MUCH AND TRYING TO BUY. MONEY
FOR PROJECTS IT BAKES THEM LESS.
CERTAIN TO BE BUILT THAT LOTS OF
THE RESULTS IN DELAYS RIGHTS
PROJECT UP. MIGHT NOT EVEN
PENCILING OUT OR WHATEVER IT
MIGHT HAPPEN SO I. AM MUCH ON
THAT SIDE OF DELIVERING THAT
SENSE AND I IT RECOGNIZE ALSO
COMMENTS ABOUT NEEDING AN
EXTERNAL PARTNER. AND THAT'S
ALSO PARTLY WHY YOU KNOW IN IN
MY HOUSE ARE PROPOSING A BILL
ABOUT HAVING A STATE SPONSORED
ENTERPRISE TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING. AND FRANKLY IT'S ALSO
INFORMED BY THE- MODEL THAT YOU
ARE PAYING HEARING YOU KNOW
FIRST OF FOREMOST YOU'RE ALL
INSTITUTIONS OF. HIGHER
EDUCATION LEARNING AND NOW
YOU'RE GETTING INTO THE BUSINESS
OF RECALL STATE. WHICH IS. VERY
INTERESTING BUT IT IS KIND OF A
LEARNING LESSON FOR US IN THE
STATE THAT. PERHAPS THERE IS A
STRONGER C. INTERVENTION IN THIS
AND IT'S ABOUT HOW DO WE
LEVERAGE RESOURCES DO SO. SO I
HOPE THAT THEY'LL BE SOME NEW
ONES AND I'M SO I COULDN'T HEAR
EVERY. COMMENT YOU'D SAID FROM
OUTSIDE THE ROOM. BUT SIDE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
SHOULD MAINTAIN AFFORDABILITY AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE- AND ALSO
HOPEFULLY WE CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN IN OUR BUDGET SO HOPEFULLY A
LOT MORE MONEY WILL COME AND
HOPEFULLY YOU GET BILL DEVELOPER
PROJECTS FASTER. ABBY'S RIGHT
NOW- EVEN THOUGH THERE'S ONE
VERY PROJECT ON THE LIST RIGHT
NOW. I REPRESENTS THE OTHER BAY
AREA. SECTION THAT IS ONE OF THE
FIVE MOST EXPENSIVE METROPOLIS
AIRS IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE MORE IN THE
BAY AREA- BUT THAT I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR ITS AND BUILDING
PERSON HOUSING TO. THANK OKAY
THANK- DOCTOR CHOI. FINAL
QUESTION IF. WE MOVE ON. YEAH
LET ME- JUST A RAY HAS- COMES TO
MY MIND- THIS PANDEMIC THAT THAT
THE WE ARE EXPERIENCING HAS A
CERTAIN NEEDS CHANGE- THE WORKER
FOR ILLNESS BY PRIVATE COMPANY
EMPLOYEES I NOTICED THAT- MANY
EMPLOYEES- NOW PICK AND CHOOSE-
THE EMPLOYMENT. BASED UPON THE
EMPLOYER SO REQUIREMENTS HOW
MANY TIMES SHOULD. A PEER TO THE
OFFICE TO WORK AND THE THEIR
PREFERENCE IS SET TO WORK LAST
SELLECCA ONCE A WEEK- AT THE-
WORKPLACE- AND OF USING THAT-
NEW TREND I THINK THAT'S
CERTAINLY OUR PARADIGM IF YOU
WENT ON TO SAY THAT THE IS A
SHIFTING AND THEN ALSO DOING
DEPEND THAT MAKE UP WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED. CAMPUS WAS SHUT
DOWN BUT THE LEARNING CONTINUED.
THROUGH TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS
ASSUME I DON'T KNOW WHAT DOES
THE MATH THOSE SO YOU HAVE
DEVELOPED TO TEACH A- AND SEVEN.
WITH HIS EXPERIENCE- I WONDER IF
WE CAN EXPLORE IT EXPLORE
FURTHER- AND IMPROVE FOR
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN-
DEFICIENT. THROUGH OFFLINE
OWNING NO I'M I'M SORRY ONLINE
LEARNING RIGHT OVER THE INTERNET
THOUGH- HOW WE CAN IMPROVE UPON
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT THE WE HAVE
RETURNED. OVER THIS UP AND THEN
MAKE UP AND ENCOURAGE AND OFFER
MORE COURSES THROUGH ONLINE
RATHER THAN PHYSICAL HOUSING.
AND WHICH WILL COST SO
OBVIOUSLY- UP TO MENDOZA MONO-
YOU KNOW TAXPAYERS MONEY WANT
UNIVERSITY A PRIVATE THE WHOEVER
GETS INVOLVED IN THE PEACE THREE
USE ETCETERA. SO- I THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT THE- EVEN BEFORE THIS
MEETING FUTURE UNIVERSITIES- THE
FISCAL NEEDS IS SEVERAL FAR. I
SHOULD BE RETHOUGHT AND THE
CHANGE THAT BECAUSE ARE THEIR
AWESOME SO CALLED A PRIVATE
COLLEGES OR UNIVERSITIES. 100%
OUR ONLINE NO CAMPERS MY EVEN
NOT- TOTALING ALL. LAST DECEMBER
SHE GOT HER. DOCTOR DEGREE IN
EVEN NURSE PRACTICE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA. AND UPON
GRADUATION I GOT TO IT. TO
PARTICIPATE THE ON CAMPUS
GRADUATION IN A GRADUATION THEY
CAN COME BUT DOES SHE HAVE TO
APPEAR AT THREE FOUR TIMES A
YEAR ON CAMPERS. OVER THE
WEEKEND SO BUT THEY IT BUT THEY-
CHI- THE TEACHING SO THERE MAY
BE CERTAIN COURSES- THAT- MAY BE
SUITABLE WAS ARE IN ON NOT NOT
SO FOR ALL ONLINE LEARNING. WHY
DON'T WE THINK GOD THAT FRAME OF
THINKING. RATHER THAN THINKING
PREPAYMENT THAT MAKE AND THE
TRADITIONAL HOUSING PROJECTS ON
HOUSING EVERYBODY HAS TO BE ON
CAMPUS I WANT TO WORK THE BEST
PERSON. ONE MAY HAVE SOME WITH
WHEN THAT. MAYBE TO JUMP IN FOR
ON THE SO I THINK YOU. A KEY
POINT ABOUT THE DESTRUCTION THAT
WE'VE SEEN ACROSS HIGHER
EDUCATION SO HIGHER EDUCATION
MOVING FORWARD IN THAT- ENDEMIC
AREA WILL NOT LOOK THE WAY THAT-
MY FAVORITE PHRASE THAT I'VE
HEARD NOW IS IN THE BEFORE
TIMES. SO IT'S NOT GONNA LOOK
THE WAY IT DID IN THE BEFORE
TIMES- AND INCLUDING OUR HOUSING
WILL NEED AND REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT- INCLUSIONS OF
TECHNOLOGY BASED LEARNING
STUDENT SUPPORTS- ALL OF THAT
NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERATION WHAT.
OUR SYSTEM IS SPEAKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SERVICE OVER 40% POSTER NATIONAL
STUDENTS THESE ARE STUDENTS THAT
ARE OVER TWENTY FIVE DON'T
REALLY LIVE THIS NOTION THAT
THEY COULD LIVE AT HOME WITH MOM
AND DAD. THAT FAMILY STRUCTURE
MAY NOT EXIST FOR THEM AND SO
FOR THESE STUDENTS HAVING
HOUSING OPTIONS IS A OF A PATH
INTO SOCIAL ECONOMIC MOBILITY-
AND IT IS A PATH OF A SECURITY
AND THAT FUNDAMENTAL- SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN ACADEMICS AND EVENTUALLY IN A
CAREER SO. WE'RE REALLY
TARGETING A VERY DIVERSE
POPULATION THAT- MAY NOT HAVE
THAT FAMILY STRUCTURE THAT
PROVIDES A HOME AND SO THAT'S
REALLY- THEY LEGISLATURES VALUE
ON INVESTING IN PROJECTS THAT
HAVE A COMMITMENT TOWARDS
AFFORDABILITY REALLY ALIGNS WITH
THAT- ELEMENT. DID YOU WANT S.
SOMEBODY ELSE YOUR QUESTION
DOCTOR CHOI. YOU KNOW IF ANYBODY
OUTSIDE. THE HOUSE OF THE FREE
ACTION. I THANK HIM FOR CHOI I
THINK OF MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COLLEAGUES CORRECT WE WON'T
EXACTLY SWING BACK TO PRE
PANDEMIC AND CAMPUSES WILL
CONTINUE TO. CREATE A SPACES-
SPECIALLY LABORATORIES TYPE
SPACES. GIVEN YOUR YOUR DAUGHTER
IN LAWS- LEARNING IN NURSING OFF
A DISTANCE DISTANCE LEARNING
BUT- WE WILL STILL HAVE THE NEED
FOR IN IN PERSON LAB COURSES AND
UNIVERSITY ART CSU STILL FINDS
IT ON CAMPUS HOUSING BENEFITS.
STUDENTS CRIED. RATE AND RETURN
. SO IT MAY NOT ALL THE WAY BACK
WHERE IT WAS BUT THEY'RE STILL.
SHARE AMOUNT OF SUPPORT AND
RESEARCH THAT HAVE BEEN BEEN
DONE TO SUPPORT ON CAMPUS-
LIVING COMMUNITIES. HEY HOUSES
JUST OF. MY AND MY PREDICTION.
MY POSITION IN THE FUTURE WHAT
BEHAVIOR AND THAT LEARNING
BEHAVIOR WE NEED TO REPHRASE OUR
THINKING AND- INSTEAD WILL-
KEEPING THE OLD TRADITION OF WAR
STALLION- FISCAL CAMPERS- HAS TO
BE THERE AND- YOU ANSWER- I MEAN
I FEEL LIKE THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO SOLVE THE OF SOCIAL PROBLEM
OTHER THAN NOT STUDENTS SO
PROBLEM WHO NEED TO BE- AT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION AND HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH WE THINK ABOUT
THE FISCAL. OF CAMPUS- AND THAT
THEY NEED TO BE HOUSE STILL AND-
BECAUSE OF THEIR INCOME LEVEL
THEY THAT THEY DO NEED TO
HOUSING BUT THE WE WHAT ABOUT
THE IF I THAT IS THE THOUGHT
TRAINS AND WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT BOUND TO COLLEGE
AND- NOT ADMITTED TO COLLEGE HOW
DO THEY SOLVE THE HOUSING
PROBLEM SO SAME SAME ISSUE THAT
THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH A SORE-
YOU KNOW I'M NOT. NOT LOOKING
FOR- IMMEDIATE ANSWER BUT THE- A
IS A FOOT THOUGHT UP FOR THE
COLLEGE ADMINISTRATION AND I
THINK THE STATE THAT WE AND WE
NEED TO- THINK ABOUT THE
REFOCUSING HOW WE CAN- SAVE OUR
RESOURCES. AND THE ASEAN E. AT
THE EFFECTIVE WHAT WAY OF A
CONTINUING ONE HIGH HIGH
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU THERE'S CERTAINLY A LOT TO-
TO CHEW ON HERE SO WE WILL. NOT
TAKE ACTION HERE HOLD OPEN- LOOK
AT THE NEXT ROUND BUT ALSO
EXPLORE WHAT TO DO. WITH STATE
MONEY RELATED COLLEGE HOUSING
BUT NEEDLESS TO SAY IT'S A IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY IN TOPIC
WE SPENT TWO HOURS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS AS THE
INTEREST OF. OF THAT THE WHOLE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR SO
EXPECT A MORE ACTION ON THIS.
THANK YOU NEXT ISSUES REALLY
ARE- VARIOUS HIGHER EDUCATION
PROPOSALS. IN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. SO OUR
SYSTEM DOES NOT. ARE YOU YOUR
COMMENT. WE ARE BUT THE PUBLIC.
REPUBLICAN MAINE WE'LL GET THE
VERY END. YES IT MAY BE AWHILE.
THE THIS. ONE OF THOSE GAMES.
NUMBER.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED YOU SHOULD
TO WE'LL HAVE TO FINANCE L. A.
O. AND CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
LEARNING LAB. HI GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS SAID JACK'S WALTZ
BERMAN FINANCE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS- THREE
PROPOSALS IN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH IS BUDGET WITH
YOU TODAY- THESE PROPOSALS ARE
THREE MILLION- JOE FUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION LEARNING
LAB ALSO KNOWN AS SELL. TWENTY
MILLION- GENERAL FUND FOR A
CLIMATE RESEARCH UP AND THREE
MILLION- GENERAL FUND FOR THE
GOLD SAID WORDS PROGRAM- OUR
FIRST PROPOSAL- THREE MILLION
FOR CELL CONSISTS OF TWO MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO RESTORE
REDUCTION IN THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE FOR GRANTS MADE AT THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT. AND A
MILLION DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH-
AND OPEN EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
PLATFORM. OUR SECOND PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE AT TWENTY MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO CURRY
SCIENCE FOR CLIMATE RESEARCH-
FACILITY IN PASADENA THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
FACING CLIMATE CHANGE HEAD ON
AND THIS INVESTMENT WILL SPUR
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT AND GREATER
STANDARD OF SOLUTION STILL AND
IMPACTS OF OUR CHANGING CLIMATE
. I THIRD AND LOTS OF ON THIS.
IS THE PER OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
TO ESTABLISH THE GOLDEN STATE
AWARDS GRANT PROGRAM FOR THE
PURPOSE OF INCENTIVIZING
CELEBRATING AND ELEVATING HIGH
IMPACT INNOVATIONS CREATING
CALIFORNIA. AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THIS MORNING AND I
AM READY ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU. OKAY
L. A. F. JASON CALLED. SOLELY IF
IT'S HELPFUL YOU CAN FOLLOW
ALONG ON PAGE FOURTEEN OF YOUR
AGENDA THAT LISTS THE EACH OF
THE THREE PROPOSALS AN ISSUE
TOO. I'LL GO THROUGH EACH EACH
ISSUE ONE AT A TIME. THE FIRST
ISSUE IT IS THE THREE MILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING GENERAL FUND
PROPOSAL FOR CELL. TWO OF TWO
MILLION OF THAT RESTORE CELLS
BUDGET TO ITS PRE PANDEMIC LEVEL
AND THEN A MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
HELP SCALE. OCCURRENCE ADAPTIVE
LEARNING TOOL THAT SELLS
CURRENTLY OVERSEEING. WE HAVE
LONG STANDING CONCERNS WITH
THIS- PROGRAM OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN IS THAT- THE ACTIVITIES
THAT SO UNDERTAKES SUPPORTING.
EDUCATIONAL INNOVATIONS A NEW
ONLINE TOOLS AND CONTENT OF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INTERVIEWS ARE ACTIVITIES THAT.
A CAMPUS IS ALREADY RECEIVE
BASED ON GOING SUPPORT TO
UNDERTAKE. IN ADDITION SINCE THE
PANDEMIC CAMPUSES HAVE- NOTABLY
INCREASED OF THEIR ENGAGEMENT
WITH THESE ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE
SPENDING A PORTION OF THEIR A
FEDERALLY FUNDING ON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. IN
LIGHT OF THAT THE PROPOSAL TO
OUR STORE SELL TO THAT'S PREPAID
DEBIT LEVEL. IS UNCLEAR TO US.
FOR THAT REASON WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL. MOVING
ALONG TO THE SECOND PROPOSAL
THAT'S THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE AWARDS.
THIS IS EFFECTIVELY ANOTHER
ROUND OF INNOVATION AWARDS OF
GOVERNORS AND PASTORS HAVE
PROPOSED HIGHER EDUCATION
INNOVATION AWARDS THEY-
TYPICALLY SUPPORT. CAMPUSES ARE
FACULTY IN UNDERTAKING WATER
CONSIDERED INNOVATIVE PRACTICES
. HELLO IN PAST YEARS HAS BEEN
SKEPTICAL THESE INNOVATION
AWARDS FOR NUMBER OF REASONS ONE
BEING THAT- THESE ARE AGAIN THE
SORTS OF ACTIVITIES THAT
CAMPUSES ARE EXPECTED TO
UNDERTAKE AS PART OF THEIR
ONGOING GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
AND ALSO BECAUSE IN PAST YEARS
THERE'S BEEN SORT OF A SMALL
NUMBER OF AWARD RECIPIENTS. AND
THEN VERY LITTLE CLEAR PATHWAY
IN TERMS OF HOW TO SCALE
INSEMINATE OTHERS BEST PRACTICES
MOVING FORWARD. IN ADDITION TO
THOSE ARE. ONGOING CONCERNS WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL IN THAT IT HAS A MUCH
BROADER SCOPE THAN PREVIOUS
INNOVATION AWARDS- WORSE
PREVIOUS INNOVATION WHERE TO
FOCUS PRIMARILY ON STUDENT
OUTCOMES. THIS WOULD ALSO FOCUS
ON CLIMATE ISSUES AND- ANY OTHER
ISSUE THAT IS THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED SORT OF INNOVATIVE
AND IMPACTFUL. GIVEN ITS BROAD
SCOPE IT'S UNLIKELY THAT THE
INITIATIVE WOULD FULLY ADDRESS
ALL THE ISSUES THAT AIMS TO
ADDRESS AND FOR THAT REASON- WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL. I'M MOVING ON TO THE
THIRD PROPOSAL THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CARNEGIE SCIENCE-
ON. CARNEGIE INSTITUTE OF
SCIENCE. OTHERS WOULD SUPPORT OF
PART OF THE COST TO CONSTRUCT A
NEW FACILITY FOR THE INSTITUTE
WHICH IS A- PRIVATE NONPROFIT
ENTITY. BECAUSE OF THE PRIVATE
NONPROFIT ENTITY THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HAVE LITTLE GUARANTEE THAT
THE- OUR ACTIVITIES UNDERTAKEN
BY THE INSTITUTE WILL ALIGN WITH
STATE OBJECTIVES. AND THEN MORE
OVER THE LEGISLATURE AS WE NOTED
IN ISSUE ONE HAS MANY OTHER
ACADEMICS. AS MANY OTHER CAPITAL
OUTLAY ISSUES INCLUDING THE
ACADEMIC FACILITY ISSUES WE
MENTIONED IN ISSUE ONE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE WAY THIS PROPOSAL
AGAINST ITS OTHER COMPETING
PRIORITIES. THE PREPONDERANCE OF
THE LEGISLATURE STILL USE THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSALS HIGH
PRIORITY. WE RECOMMENDED
MODIFYING THE PROPOSAL TO
INCLUDE SOME ADDITIONAL INTENT
AND REPORTING LANGUAGE. FOR THE
SECOND TIME I WON'T GO INTO
DETAIL ON EACH EACH
RECOMMENDATION BUT THE OVERALL
INTENT IS TO CLARIFY THE STATE'S
ROLE IN SUPPORTING THIS PROJECT.
AND TO GET SOME MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE PROJECT ONCE IT'S
COMPLETED. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER HI MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS LARK PARK DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
LEARNING LAB THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY- THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
LEARNING LAB WAS AUTHORIZED IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT
AS A PROGRAM DEDICATED TO
IMPROVING LEARNING OUTCOMES AND
CLOSING EQUITY GAPS ACROSS THE
UCCS USING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE LEARNING LAB IS EXACTLY THAT
IT'S ALLOWED TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW TO IMPROVE.
TEACHING AND LEARNING AND THEN
SCALE THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
PROMISING PRACTICES- TO FOSTER
GREATER STUDENT SUCCESS WE
ACHIEVE THIS BY INCENTIVIZING
FACULTY INNOVATION- THAT IT IS
UNDER A COMPETITIVE GRANT MODEL
WITH EXPERTS AS SELECT THE MOST
PROMISING PRO FOR AWHILE R. A.
EXPERT US LAW AND OF INCLUDE A
NOBEL LAUREATE IN PHYSICS AND
INNOVATOR AT AMAZON- EXPERT
INSIDE AT. AND EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGIES AS WELL AS FACULTY
LEADERS WHO ARE WELL KNOWN FOR
ADVANCING DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION- ACROSS A PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION WE HAVE BROAD
REACH DEAD SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN
WE FUNDED THIRTY NINE PROJECTS
THAT INVOLVE ALL NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES OF THE UC
TWENTY OUT OF THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES A CSU IN FORTY THREE OF
THE HUNDRED SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE PROJECTS
ALSO USE THAT MAKE USE OF A
STATE WIDE SYSTEM WIDE-
NETWORKS. WE NEED NOTED OUR
BUDGET REQUEST OF TWO MILLION TO
RESTORE GRANTMAKING CAPACITY TO
PRETEND THAT MAKE LEVELS AND A
MILLION TO EXPAND AND- WE ARE
PLATFORM TO DELIVER FREE AND LOW
COST STEM HOMEWORK SYSTEMS TO
STUDENTS AND WE BELIEVE THESE
WILL BE BOTH BOTH WORTHWHILE
AFTER THE STATE TO INVEST IN OUR
FUNDED PROJECTS OFFER MUCH MORE
THAN THE AVERAGE REDESIGNED
COURSE IN ADDITION TO BEING
EQUITY FOCUSED AND
TECHNOLOGICALLY SOPHISTICATED
THEY OFFER US STUDENTS A CHANCE
TO LEARN MORE DEEPLY AND THEY'RE
BASED ON INTER SEGMENTAL
COLLABORATION TO MAXIMIZE IMPACT
ACROSS ALL THREE SEGMENTS- AND
THEY ALSO CLOSE THE MEASURE
EFFECTS ON STUDENTS AND FACULTY-
AS AN EXAMPLE ONE OF OUR FUNDED
PRO. FOCUSED ON CHEMISTRY WORK
TO REALLY REDEFINE WHAT IT MEANS
TO DO SCIENCE AND IN THE
CLASSROOM AT LOWER DIVISION
LEVELS- AND THEY'RE SEEING GAINS
OF MORE THAN 18% IN STUDENT
SUCCESS. AND I ALMOST SEVENTEEN
PERCENT- AND IMPROVEMENTS IN
RETENTION- AND LIKE WHY IS IT A
BIT IN A BEER PROJEC FOCUSED ON
BIG IDEAS IN MATHEMATICS-
THERE'S SEEING GREATER
COMPLETION RATES OF UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS- BY
FOURTEEN PLUS PERCENTAGE POINTS
SO. ARE PROJECTS ARE ACTUALLY
HAVING A REALLY POSITIVE IMPACT
. FINALLY IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT
ALTHOUGH ONLINE AND HYBRID
ENVIRONMENTS OR NATIVE
ENVIRONMENTS FOR MANY OF OUR
PROJECTS AND WE DEFINE HYBRID
VERY BROADLY- THE MATERIALS THAT
THEY'VE DEVELOPED THEIR ALL OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES THEY'RE
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO BE. ADAPTED
AND APPLICABLE TO ALL THESE
COURSE SETTINGS AND SO WE
BELIEVE INVESTING IN THIS
PROGRAM IS A BASIC R&D PROGRAM
HELPS INCREASE THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT INTO HIGHER EDUCATION
WHICH IS- WHICH IS ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY-
AND THIS DEDICATED FUNDING HAS
MEANT A GREAT DEAL TO FACULTY IN
THAT IT SENDS A REALLY STRONG
MESSAGE TO THEM. THE STATE
REALLY CARES ABOUT INNOVATION IN
TEACHING AND LEARNING FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS- I'M SEPARATE
ITEM OF THE GOLDEN STATE AWARDS
WELL I WOULD JUST LIKE TO NOTE.
REGARDING ALEJO'S CONCERNS AT
THE EXACT PARAMETERS OF THE
GOLDEN STATE AWARDS- THEY DO
REMAIN UNSTATED BUT ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF THIS APPROACH IS
REALLY. TO ALLOW- A LOOK ALLOW
US TO ASK TODAY'S INNOVATORS-
WHAT WOULD THAT THE BEST DESIGN
OF THIS AWARD PROGRAM LOOKS LIKE
WE COULD WE HAVE SO MANY US. AN
INCREDIBLE INNOVATORS AT THE
STATE I CALIFORNIA'S LIKE
JENNIFER DOUDNA AND ANDREA GAZ
WERE BOTH IN A RECENT NOBEL
LAUREATES THEY CAN ACTUALLY.
PROVIDE INPUT- ON HOW CALIFORNIA
COULD MAKE THE MOST OF THIS
FUNDING AND INNOVATORS DO NOT
REST ON THEIR LAURELS-
INNOVATION DOESN'T REALLY HAPPEN
OKAY. TO A FIVE POINT YOU KNOW
PRE. PLAN AND SO THE FLEXIBILITY
TO MAKE THIS. MAKE THIS AWARDS
PROGRAM AS EFFECTIVE AS
POSSIBLE- TO BOTH CELEBRATE AND
PROMOTE INNOVATION- THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY HERE IN TERMS OF
GIVING SPACE. TODAY'S INNOVATORS
TO HELP US DESIGNED THIS
PROGRAM- I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU. I HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR YOU OF THESE ITEMS
WE WILL ALL THE ISSUES OPEN.
WALDRON MATHIS STOOD ON- JUST TO
HAVE- I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION ON
THE CELL- THE DISEASE IS ALSO
BEING THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS ALSO DEVELOPING
CLASSES. THAT OCCURRED IS THE IS
THE- ONLINE HIGHER EDUCATION
COURSES COMMITTEE CALLED ALSO I
SEE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING THE CELL EFFORT
YES VERY MUCH SO FORTY THREE AT
A HUNDRED SIXTEEN- CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
REPRESENTED OUR THIRTY NINE
PROJECTS THAT WE'VE AWARDED
TODAY YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THIS QUESTION I JUST
WONDER WHY THEY'RE PARTICIPATING
IN THIS AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
CALIBRATE. BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM
IS NOT. EXCLUSIVELY DEDICATED TO
ONLINE COURSES AND IT'S NOT
DEDICATED TO- TARGETING A
DIFFERENT POPULATION IT TARGETS
THE EXISTING POPULATION AND IT
HAS A FACULTY WORKING ACROSS THE
THREE SEGMENTS. ON PROJECTS-
PRIMARILY IN STEM AND SO THE
MATERIALS IN THE RESOURCES IN
THE PROJECTS ARE REALLY
APPLICABLE TO ALL DIFFERENT
TYPES OF COURSES ONLINE HYBRID-
WHICH WE'VE ACTUALLY DEFINED
QUITE BROADLY. SOME WHAT WHAT MY
THESE COURSES LOOK I'M A STUDENT
CLASSROOM IS KIND OF A CANDLER
COURSE SECOND SHEET THAT I
COULD. IT'S ONLINE I ASSUME ARE
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
ONLINE IT IT OR NOT ONLINE AT
ALL. NO SOME OF THEM ARE ONLINE
AND SOME OF THEM ARE HYBRID
COURSES AND SO THE MATERIALS
THAT ARE DEVELOPED FOR THESE FOR
THESE PROJECTS THEY CAN WORKING
AN ONLINE CONTEXT FOR A HYBRID
CONTEXT OR AN IN PERSON CONTACT
. IS THAT WHAT IT'S KIND OF A
PROJECT LEARNING APPROACH OF
YOU. KNOW UP THE BY PROJECT WE
MEAN THE PROJECTS THAT WE AWARD-
SO FACULTY GET TOGETHER THEY
PROPOSE A PROJECT FOR HOW TO-
IMPROVE STUDENT LEARNING. LET'S
SAY. COURSE OR CALCULUS COURSE
BY ALL COURSE- AND SO THEY WILL
BRING IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
APPROACHES THEY'LL- THEY'LL HAVE
A RESEARCH DESIGN ABOUT WHAT
THEY MEANT. MEASURE WHAT THEY
THINK WILL HAPPEN WITH STUDENT
SUCCESS AND THEN THEY REPORT OUT
THE RESULTS OFWHAT ACTUALLY
CHANGED AND SOME OF THE OUTCOMES
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER- I HAVE
SEEN IT THERE THERE BEEN SOME
QUITE POSITIVE OUTCOMES ON
STUDENT SUCCESS AND RETENTION.
OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
HOLD THIS ISSUE OFTEN. AS YOU
NUMBER THREE CAL KIDS
IMPLEMENTATION. THE-
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS AND W.
LIKE HAVE. BECAUSE IT'S AN
INCREASE OF FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR
NOTIFICATION AND MARKETING COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
KIDS INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPMENT
SAVINGS PROGRAM CAO KIDS THE
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION I'M
GOING GENERAL FUND FOR FINANCIAL
LITERACY OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT
WILL INFORM FAMILIES OF THE LONG
TERM BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE COPY ITS PROGRAM IN TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT TO ADDITIONAL STAFF
WHAT THEY CALL GETS PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE MINISTRATION
PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND I'M GOING GENERAL
FUND. TO SUPPORT COSTS FOR A
NEED TO CREATE A RECORDKEEPING
PLATFORM. AND CRITICAL IT NEEDS
FOR THE CAUCUS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY ALAIA GOOD
MORNING CAN MEMBERS BASICALLY
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THIS ISSUE COVERS
SEVERAL PROPOSALS RELATING TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COCKETTES PROGRAM. WE DON'T HAVE
CONCERNS REGARDING THAT TO
PROPOSED POSITIONS OR THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
AUGMENTATION INCLUDED IN THIS
FROM FINANCE WATER AND SO
INSTEAD FOCUS MY COMMENTS AND
THE REMAINING PROPOSALS WHICH
RELATE OUTREACH. IF YOU TURN THE
PAGE TWENTY ONE OF HERNANDEZ
THAT FIGURE AT THE TOP HERE
SUMMARIZES THE GOVERNOR'S AT
WHICH PROPOSALS AS ALSO
DESCRIBED BY MY COLLEAGUE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THERE ARE
TWO ISSUES WE WOULD RAISE
REGARDING THAT REACH PROPOSALS.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS HAVE SOME OVERLAPPING
PURPOSES THAT PARTICIPANT
NOTIFICATION AND MARKETING
CAMPAIGN ARE INTENDED TO MAKE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AWARE OF THEIR CALL KIDS
ACCOUNTS. WELL THE FINANCIAL
LITERACY AVERAGE PROPOSALS
INTENDED TO INFORM THEM OF THE
BENEFITS OF SAVING WITH THOSE
ACCOUNTS. HERE WE THINK THERE
MIGHT BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSOLIDATE THESE PROPOSALS INTO
ONE SO THAT WE CAN SEND A MORE
UNIFIED MESSAGE TO STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AND POTENTIALLY
ALSO REDUCE DUPLICATION ACROSS
INITIATIVES. THIS ISSUE WOULD
RAISE REGARDING THAT RICH
PROPOSALS IS SPECIFIC TO THE
FINANCIAL LITERACY COMPONENT
THAT FIVE MILLION ONGOING. READ
LIMITED DETAIL ON THE SPECIFIC
ONGOING FINANCIAL LITERACY
ACTIVITIES THAT THE SCHOLARSHIP
INVESTMENT BOARD WOULD UNDERTAKE
WITH THESE FUNDS. IN ADDITION
THE PROPOSED FUNDING LEVEL THE
FIVE MILLION IS NOT DIRECTLY
LINKED TO THE COST OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES. AND SO REGARDING THE
FINANCIAL LITERACY WE WOULD
RECOMMEND WITHHOLDING ACTION ON
THIS PROPOSAL AND REQUESTING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE
A MORE DETAILED. PROPOSAL THAT
SATISFIES WHAT ACTIVITIES WOULD
OCCUR. YES MY ACOSTA IS
ACTIVITIES AND MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO COORDINATE THEM
WITH THE RELATED PARTISAN
NOTIFICATION A MARKETING
CAMPAIGN. THANK YOU HAPPY TAKEN
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU THIS
SCHOLARS YOUR INVESTMENT BIRTH.
HI NEWSSTANDS YOU KNOW FROM THE
US CULTURE INVESTMENT BOARD
THANK YOU. YEAH THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND- MEMBERS OF THE OF
BUDGET SUB SUB COMMITTEE- ON
MANY STANDS VETO FROM THE- SASHA
INVESTMENT BOARD I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL. SURE ALL CALLS WILL
START OUT WITH SOME JUST
TECHNICAL QUESTION SO THIS HAS
BEEN A PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MANY YEARS AND
WITH OUR- YOU KNOW ONCE IN A
GENERATION BUDGET LAST YEAR WE
WERE ABLE TO GO. VERY VERY BIG
ON THIS. SO- WE HAD THIS ONE
TIME INFUSION TO START THIS TO
GET PEOPLE IT COUNTS AND THAT
ONGOING MONEY TO KEEP SEATING
THAT SO WHAT'S THE STATUS ON.
LETTING SINCE THE MILLIONS OF
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA NO
HAY. HERE YOU GO HERE'S AN
ACCOUNT FOR YOU. YEAH YET THE
STATUSES WERE WORKING ON A
TOWARD A LAUNCH IN JULY AND-
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS- AN ITEM
MENTIONED IN HERE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE NOTIFICATIONS ON THAT
WOULD GO OUT TO ALL OF THE- A
PICTURE WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE SO. YOUR FAMILY YOU HAVE NO
IDEAS HAPPEN YOU KNOW FOLLOW
STATE GOVERNMENT. YOU KNOW YOU
GET MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF MAIL IN
YOUR- L. BOX EVERY DAY. MOST OF
ITS JUNK MAIL AND PEOPLE TRYING
TO RIP YOU OFF WITH CREDIT CARDS
ARE SUDDENLY. BLOWN THIS AND
THAT SO HOW WE'RE GONNA BREAK
THROUGH. AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO
KNOW THAT THIS IS REAL AND NOT
SOME SCAM. OR VAGUE WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
MINISTRATION AND- THE- AS FAR AS
LIKE WORKING TOWARDS LAUNCH
WERE- JUST TAKING A PICTURE
WHAT'S IS GONNA LOOK LIKE IF
YOUR FAMILY A MILE FROM HERE.
AND IN YOUR MAILBOX EVERY DAY
ARE CREDIT CARD THINGS AND THIS
AND THAT IT JUST LOOKS LIKE
ANOTHER WHEN THESE THINGS ARE
TRYING TO GET ME SO LIKE HOW ARE
WE GOING TO BREAK THROUGH AND-
TAKING A PICTURE HOW FAMILIES
CAN UNDERSTAND THIS IT'S GOING
TO BE A COMBINATION OF THE
NOTIFICATIONS AS WELL AS JUST.
THE MARKETING OUR EACH COMPONENT
WE ALSO MENTIONED BEFORE- WORK
IN PROGRESS WITH PREPARING THIS
NOTIFICATION TO WAS VERY CLEAR
AND DIRECT IN TERMS OF- WHAT THE
PROGRAM IS- AS FAR AS LIKE WHOSE
WHOSE- WHO'S ADMINISTERING IT-
AND- WE HAVE A WEBSITE UP THAT
SUPPOSED TO BE VERY INFORMATIVE-
FOR FOLKS- TO GET AS MUCH
INFORMATION AND TO GET TO THE
WEBSITE TO REGISTER WERE ALSO
PLANNING TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH ORGANIZATIONS AND SCHOOLS.
TO MAKE SURE THE INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM ONCE WE GET
ALL THE DATA AND INFORMATION
OUT- WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND- AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO MAKE SURE THAT ON
THE NOTIFICATIONS GO OUT ON TIME
AND- ON A REGULAR BASIS IN
COMBINATION WITH ALL OF THE
OTHER OUT REACH UPI REACH
ACTIVITIES THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING SO FIRST OF ALL DON'T GET
ME WRONG I'M I'M A HUGE BELIEVER
IN THIS I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR YEARS AND- PEOPLE HAVE
A COLLEGE ACCOUNTS ARE LIKE
EIGHT TIMES MORE LIKELY TO GO ON
TO COLLEGE AS YOU KNOW. TO SET
EXPECTATIONS MORE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION
AND WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TO GO TO
COLLEGE FOR OUR ECONOMY. BUT I
JUST THINK IT'S GONNA BE. REALLY
COMPLICATED BECAUSE SO MANY YOU
GET YOUR MAIL. IT'S LIKE HEY YOU
WIN CALL THIS NUMBER FOR THIS
AND THAT AND LIKE EVERYTHING IS
TOO GOOD TO BE TRUE HE KICKED IN
YOUR MAILBOX. ON A DAILY DAILY
BASIS I JUST THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE. REALLY HARD. TO ENABLE
FAMILIES NOW THIS IS LEGIT THIS
IS REAL THE UP TO SIGN UP. SO IT
THE LANDS THAT WE NEED IT LENDS
THE- NOTION THAT WE NEED. MUCH
MORE THAN JUST. A LETTER OR
MULTIPLE LETTERS. IN THE MAIL SO
THE HARDENER SHIPS WOULD SCHOOLS
OR I KNOW THAT THERE'S PROPOSALS
TAKING A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN WE
DID THIS WE DID JUST GREAT THE
COUNCIL GAVE MONEY TO THESE.
PARTNERSHIPS AND COLLABORATIVES
IN DIFFERENT CITIES LIKE OAKLAND
HAS THAT. COLLEGE PROMISE THING
WEST SACRAMENTO HAS A PROGRAM WE
HAVE ONE HERE IN THE CITY
SACRAMENTO SMALLER ONE SO DO WE
UTILIZE THESE TO HELP. SPREAD
THE WORD ENGAGE PEOPLE KINDA
LIKE WE DO WITH. THE L. CENSUS
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH TYPE STUFF
BECAUSE I JUST THINK THEY- DID
THAT ON THE NATURAL. SENDING
LETTERS TO THE L. THREE MILLION
FAMILIES IS NOT GONNA WORK. AND
IF I MAY JUST SAD I'M CURRENTLY
CHAO'S WITH THE PALM NO FINANCE-
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
ONE BILLION TO GROW- PROVIDE
MARKETING SERVICES TO ITS
CULTURE INVESTMENT MORE.
SURPRISED THAN INCLUDED CABLE
TV- ADS THROUGHOUT THE STATE. N.
ADDITIONALLY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A FIVE MILLION
I'M GOING FINANCIAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVES AS THIS WILL BE TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
PROGRAM AND LEARN ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF ACCRUED BENEFITS
ACCRUE INTEREST. AND I WOULD
ALSO BRING- A LOT MORE IN
INFORMATION TO THE FAMILIES WHO
. OKAY AND JUST TO KNOW WE MAY
HAVE THAT SLIGHT TWEAK OF. THAT
LAST YEAR'S MONEY TO FOCUS ON.
IMPLEMENTATION IS AS WELL. OKAY
I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER.
QUESTIONS ON THIS MISTER
O'DONNELL. YEAH I TO ME JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
THIS IN THIS ISN'T YOUR FAULT
RIGHT THIS IS A HUGE HURDLE I
THINK ON IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM SO- THE HOW DOES THIS
WORK DOESN'T HAPPEN AT BIRTH
BACK ENACT AN ACCOUNT IS
AUTOMATICALLY OPEN ONCE A CHILD
WAS GIVEN A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. AND IF SO WHERE DOES
THAT MONEY GO WHAT INVESTMENT
FIRM ECCENTRIC AND IF NOT TO
SOMEONE GET A CHECK MAILED TO
THEIR HOME HOW DO WE KNOW THEY
INVESTED IT- AND OR- AND OR CASH
IT OUT LATER- I'M LOOKING AT
SOME OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH THAT.
OUNCE FROM HOME TO HOME HOW
WOULD WE ENSURE THAT THEIR
PROJECT I'M SURE THIS VERY
DIFFICULT ON HOW THIS IS ALL
GOING TO BE. IMPLEMENTED SO I
CERTAINLY WANT TO START OFF WITH
SAYING I APPRECIATE. THE
SIGNIFICANCE- IN THE HIGH
HURDLES YOU HAVE TO IMPLEMENTING
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS SO WITHOUT
ALL. LEE AND STATE STANDARDS
CULTURE ESTIMATES- SO BASICALLY
YOU HAVE TO POPULATION GROUPS OF
THE NEWBORN POPULATION GROUP AND
THEN ALSO THE SCHOOL AGE
POPULATION GROUP. SAW WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH- FIRST OF ALL
WE'LL START WITH THE NEWBORN
POPULATION WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH. A TWO ON CLICK THE
NECESSARY BIRTH REGISTRATION
DATA THAT WOULD BE UTILIZED TO-
IDENTIFY- AND CONTACT THE FOLKS.
IT IS AN OPT OUT PROGRAM MEANING
THAT THE ACCOUNT TO BE OPENED-
FOR THE NEWBORNS SO IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF- MAKING WE'RE MAKING
THEM AWARE THAT IT'D JUST THAT
THEY CAN. GO ON REGISTER AXIS IT
VIEW THEIR ACCOUNT BALANCE- AND
THEN THERE FOR- ALSO. INTEGRATE
THE- COMPONENT TO EDUCATE THEM
ABOUT SCHOLAR SHARE. ON IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN THEIR OWN
ACCOUNT AND CONTRIBUTE
REGULARLY- FOR THE OTHER
POPULATION OF THE SCHOOL AGE
POPULATION WE SIMILARLY WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION.
TO DO SOMETHING SIMILAR WITH
WITH THE KIDS AND THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE TO
NOTIFY THEM. IN COMBINATION WITH
A COMPREHENSIVE MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS AND WORKING WITH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THESE OTHER
GROUPS AND IN THE SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS. TO MAKE SURE ALL THE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ARE AWARE
THAT THE PROGRAMS THERE AND WITH
CLEAR INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW. TO GO
ONLINE AND- ACCESS THE ACCOUNTS.
TO SERVE AS A DATE AND TIME WHEN
EVERY CHILD BORN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I ASSUME WE'LL GET AN
ACCOUNT. HEY IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE BEGINNING DATE- IT'S
ON. JULY NE TWO THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO AS WE GET THE
BIRTH REGISTRATION DATA FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH- AN ACCOUNT WILL
BE OPEN NO MA'AM ACCOUNT THE
ACCOUNT NUMBER TO FIVE TWENTY
NINE. I ASSUME. RIGHT CORRECT
OKAY- AND WHERE SO WHERE IS THE
FILE AS IT IS THE FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PUT INTO A MONTH IT'S
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS I BELIEVE
RIGHT. IS IT AND IT WARRANT IS A
DIFFERENT AMOUNT- IT'S- TO
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO START.
CAN WE FIGHT ALSO HAS SOME OF
THE DIGITAL CENTER IS THERE FOR
THE SCHOOL AGE POPULATION IS
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS- AND THEN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED IF
THEY'RE- HOMELESS. AND ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED IF THEY'RE FOSTER
USE. SO IS THAT PUT INTO A MONEY
MARKET WHOSE INVESTMENT FIRM WHO
SELECTS AN INVESTMENT FIRM. DOES
THE FAMILY HAVE TO THEN OPEN AN
ADDITIONAL ACCOUNT OF THE DESIRE
pTO PUT MORE MONEY INTO IT OR
COULD THEY JUST ADDED TO THE-
ACCOUNT. THAT WAS OPENED AT
BIRTH HOW HOW WOULD ALL THAT
WORK- FOR THE NEWBORNS THEY'RE
GOING TO BE PUT INTO AN ACCOUNT-
WITH SMALLER SHARE ON. THE FIFTH
OF. THE HEAT THE ADDRESS ARE
OPTIONAL BOARD SELECTS THAT
MEETS. MEETS THAT PARTICULAR
POPULATIONS INVESTMENT PRACTICE-
THEY ARE GOING TO GIVEN UP. BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN
THEIR OWN CULTURE COUNT. AND
LINK THE TWO ACCOUNTS SO THEY
CAN VIEW BOTH BALANCES- BECAUSE
THEY THEY- THEY WILL BE ABLE
CONTRIBUTE DIRECTED OF CALKINS
ACCOUNT THAT THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO THEIR OWN SCHOLARSHIP KILKA.
SO WITH IN THE CALIFORNIA I'M
THE CALIBER DOLLARS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA GOING TO WHAT TYPE
IS IT A MONEY MARKET IS IT A-AND S. AND P. FIVE HUNDRED WHAT
KIND WHAT WHAT'S THE INVESTMENT
VEHICLE THEY WOULD YEARS
BECAUSE- A MONEY MARKETS NOT
GONNA EARN. MUCH MONEY RIGHT THE
STOCK MARKET'S GONNA DO THEM.
MUCH BETTER THAN A MONEY MARKET
WOULD TRADITIONALLY. SO WHAT.
WHO SELECTS THAT VEHICLE YEAH IT
WOULD DEPEND ON THE POPULATION
FOR INSTANCE NEWBORNS- SINCE
THEY HAVE A LONG TIME ORIZON
THEY WOULD BE PUT INTO A ON. A
WHAT WE CALL A- IN ROAMING YOUR
PORTFOLIO THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. ON THAT
STRETCH OF MORE CONSERVATIVE AND
ADJUSTS- A SORTS OF MORE
RESIDENT BECOMES MORE
CONSERVATIVE AS THEY AGED. SO
THAT THE IDEAS THAT THE
INVESTMENT OPTIONS SELECTED FOR
EACH- POPULATION WOULD FIT
THEIR- INVESTMENT OBJECTIVES AND
INVESTMENT HORIZON. OKAY THANK
YOU. YEAH I JUST JUST BACK TO
THIS- SO WE HAVE SIX MILLION
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA. ROUGHLY
MAYBE LET'S SAY HALF OUR LOW
INCOME I'M NOT SURE WHAT TO SAY.
JUST FOR MY- YOU KNOW IT'S AN
EXAMPLE HERE THREE MILLION KIDS
AND MAYBE THAT'S NOT. LESS THAN
THREE MILLION FAMILIES SO TV AD
OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE FOR TWO
MILLION. AS SEEMS LIKE A TOTAL
WASTE OF MONEY HAVING THIS
MASSIVE TV CAMPAIGN WHEN THE
SIMPLE THING IS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WORK TO
THE WORK WITH THESE KIDS ON A
DAILY BASIS. SO I'M NOT SURE WHY
WE'RE NOT. FOCUSING THEIR SELF
WE NEED TO I THANK. REVISIT THIS
AND EFFECTIVE LIKE WE WANT THIS
TO WORK. AND WE AND WE AND I AND
I KNOW FOR EXAMPLE FOR A
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE BECAUSE- AS A
CITY COUNCILMEMBER HERE FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO I CREATED ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS READ RAISE PRIVATE
MONEY. CREATED COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS FOR FAMILIES AND OPEN
THEM UP WE HAD A CREDIT UNION UP
OPEN THE ACCOUNTS. AND MOST THE
FAMILIES WERE LIKE THIS IS TOO
GOOD TO BE TRUE. HE HAD
IMMIGRATION ISSUES I DON'T WANNA
FILL PAPERWORK THEY'RE SKEPTICAL
ON THIS AND THAT AND IT WAS LIKE
NOW THIS IS MONEY FOR YOUR KID
TO GO TO COLLEGE. AND WHEN WE
TALK TO THEM LIKE OH MY GOD
THAT'S AMAZING BUT LIKE YOU HAD
TO HAVE A ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATION. BUT JUST EVEN.
SENDING THEM FOR ME INFORMATION
EVEN IN THE PACKAGES IT WAS RICK
THAT'S REALLY REALLY HARD. L.
DISTINCT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
JUST ALL OF US SAID CREATE THESE
ACCOUNTS INCIDENTS PEOPLE THE
MAIL ON THIS OFFICES CAN BE
GOOD. THAT'S NOT GONNA WORK SO.
I THINK WE NEED TO. TAKE A LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN UTILIZE OUR
EXISTING. MODES OF
COMMUNICATION. TO DO THIS AND
EFFECTIVE WAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
YES I THINK YOU'RE ON TO
SOMETHING THERE BUT I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT IF WE ARE GOING TO TURN
THIS OVER THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
RIGHT. THEY NEED TO SEE RECEIVE
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS BECAUSE I. AS YOU'RE
POINTING OUT- THERE'S A LOT OF
LOGISTICS. PROBABLY VERIFICATION
ETCETERA THAT HAVE TO GO ON.
WITH AN EFFORT LIKE THIS SO I
JUST HOPE THAT AS WE CONTEMPLATE
ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAT WE
ALREAY GOT PLAN. THAT WE
REALIZE IT'S SCHOOL DISTRICTS
NEED TO BE. RESOURCE DIVIDE.
THEIR NORTH OKAY WE WILL- PULL
THIS ISSUE OPEN. FOR ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. STUDENT LOAN
BORROWER OF ASSISTANCE.
K. YEAH OKAY THE NEW TESTIFIES
HERE. OKAY SO WE HAVE- D. O. F.
L. A. O. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PROTECTION. SO FIRST DIAZ ABOUT
REBEKAH KIRK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IN RESPONSE THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION POTS
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENTS WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY SCHEDULED TO
RESUME IN SEPTEMBER OF THIS
YEAR. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION OR DF
PI TO IMPLEMENT THE STUDENT LOAN
BORROWER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES THE GRANT
PROGRAM AND MARKETING CAMPAIGN
TO ASSIST CALIFORNIA STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS IN UNDERSTANDING
THEIR RIGHTS OPTIONS AND WHERE
TO FIND ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
STATUTORY CHANGES OUTLINING
PROGRAM PARAMETERS AND PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY FOR D. F. P. I. TO
ADJUST TO ANY FUTURE CHANGES
THAT MAY BE IMPOSED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FINALLY THIS
PROPOSAL WILL FILL GAPS IN THE
EXISTING RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS
IN CALIFORNIA. LEVERAGE THE
STATE'S KNOWLEDGE ON CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC STUDENT LOAN BORROWING
LAWS TO PROVIDE CLEAR AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION. AND
UTILIZE EXISTING COMMUNITY BASED
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT CAN WORK DIRECTLY WITH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
FURTHER OUR REACH EFFORTS TO
THESE BORROWERS. IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL. MY
COLLEAGUES ANDREW **** AND
KIMBERLY HARBISON ARE AVAILABLE
VIA WEBEX TO ADDRESS THEM AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU L. A. L. THANK YOU I
COME FROM THIS PROPOSAL
APPEARING INTENDED BEGINNING AT
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TWENTY SIX.
THE PROPOSAL IS PRIMARILY
INTENDED TO PROVIDE ACCURATE AND
TIMELY INFORMATION TO STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS ABOUT THEIR LOAN
REPAYMENT OPTIONS. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED APPROACH AND I'LL
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THEM. THE
FIRST CONCERN IS THAT THERE ARE
MANY EXISTING SOURCES OF
INFORMATION ON STUDENT LOANS AND
REPAYMENT. INCLUDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS
FROM COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES NOT
IDENTIFY THE SPECIFIC GAPS IN
INFORMATION THAT REMAINED AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR THESE EXISTING
SOURCES. MOREOVER SOME ELEMENTS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IF
YOU'RE A DUPLICATE THESE
EXISTING RESOURCES. FOR EXAMPLE
SOME OF THE PROPOSED FUNDS WOULD
BE USED TO CREATE A BORROWER
FACING WEBSITE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON STUDENT LOANS.
ALTHOUGH THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARE TO MAINTAIN SUCH A
WEBSITE. CONCERN WE HAVE RELATES
TO THE USE OF ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
THIS PURPOSE. PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS IS IN MANY WAYS AN
ONGOING ACTIVITY WITH THE NEW
COHORT OF BORROWERS ENTERING
REPAYMENT EVERY YEAR AND
REQUIRING INFORMATION. WELL THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COULD REACH
CURRENT BARS IN THE NEAR TERM
THERE ISN'T A CLEAR PROVISION TO
SUSTAIN HIS ACTIVITIES AFTER THE
FUNDING EXPIRES. OUR CONCERN
ABOUT USING ONE TIME FUNDS IN
THIS WAY IS THAT IT COULD LEAD
TOA SHORT LIVED IMPACT WHILE
CREATING PRESSURE FOR THE STATE
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THIS PURPOSE DOWN THE LINE.
WHAT ADDITIONAL CONCERN WE HAVE
RELATES TO THE CONTINUED CHANGES
IN FEDERAL POLICY RELATED TO
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT. AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES NOTED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SUSPENDED
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENTS THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC. SINCE
THAT INITIAL PAUSE WAS PUT IN
PLACE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
EXTENDED THE PAUSE SB SIX TIMES.
AND OF THE STATE REMAINS
UNCERTAIN WHETHER REPAYMENTS
WILL RESUME IN SEPTEMBER IS
ORIGINALLY SCHEDULED OR IF THAT
DATE WILL BE FURTHER POSTPONED.
THIS UNCERTAINTY COULD AFFECT
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT
A TIMELY INFORMATION CAMPAIGN IN
THE BUDGET CARE. ALSO
POTENTIALLY. IMPACTING THE
RELEVANCE OF THAT INFORMATION
THE BUDGET YEAR. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
THAT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS
ASSISTANCE BE HAVING TAKEN
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU NOW HERE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND CRUCIAL TO
THE CHIEF DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION. AT THIS
PROPOSAL IS ONE OF GOVERNOR
NUISANCE PRIORITIES THE FEDERAL
LOAN REPAYMENT RESTARTED HERE
HAS BEEN CHANGED SEVERAL TIMES
IN THE PAST YEAR- IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE FUNDS BE APPROVED THIS
SPRING SO WE'RE READY TO GO
WHENEVER THE IDEN MINISTRATION
PLANS ON THE FINAL DATE TO
RESTART THESE STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENTS. SECOND I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES OR NONPROFITS MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR EXPANDED PUBLIC
SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS IF THEY
TAKE SPECIFIC ACTION BY OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST WE CAN HELP THESE
CALIFORNIANS GET THEIR STUDENT
LOANS FORGIVEN. AND THAT'S MONEY
THAT THEY CAN SPEND EVERY MONTH
INTO THE FUTURE. THE PROPOSAL
DOES INCLUDE FLEXIBILITY FOR D.
F. P. I. TO ADJUST THE TIMING OF
OUR EFFORTS IF THE- STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT RESTART IS MOVED
AGAIN. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO HAVE MONEY IN THE
FIELD WHEN. THESE DATES ARE
ANNOUNCED WITH ME AS MY
COLLEAGUE SUZANNE MARTINDALE
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER SHE'S
A NATIONWIDE EXPERT ON STUDENT
LOAN ISSUES. AND CHILL OUT A
LITTLE BIT. THANK YOU CHRIS. A
TIME OF GREAT ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY AND ONGOING
FLUCTUATIONS IN FEDERAL POLICY.
IT'S CRUCIAL FOR STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS IN REPAYMENT
UNDERSTAND THEIR OPTIONS AND FOR
BORROWERS TO LEARN HOW TO SPOT
SCAMS AND REPORT TROUBLING LOAN
SERVICER BEHAVIOR TO OUR
DEPARTMENT WE REGULATE STUDENT
LOAN SERVICERS. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO ALMOST FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE WITH OUTSTANDING FEDERAL
STUDENT LOANS THAT HAVE BEEN ON
PAUSE SINCE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY.
WITH HIS REPEATED SHORT TERM
EXTENSIONS THE PAYMENT POTS BY
THE WHITE HOUSE BUT NO LONGER
TERM PLAN GET INSIDE AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. BORROWERS ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY ANXIOUS ABOUT
WHAT THAT WHEN THEY HAVE TO
START REPAYING THE VERY WARY. OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S MIXED
MESSAGES WE ARE WORKINGIN CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WHICH IS
ACTIVELY URGING STATE REGULATORS
LIKE THE FBI. TO PRIORITIZE
BORROWER OUTREACH AND ASSISTANCE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE PARTICULARLY
BETWEEN NOW AND OCTOBER THIRTY
FIRST WHEN THE PSLF WAIVER
EXPIRES. THE WAY TO HOLDING
THESE LOANS AND MANAGING THEM IS
REAL I CAN TELL YOU FROM MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS SOMEONE
WHO HAD STUDENT LOANS.
PARTICIPATED IN THE PSLF PROGRAM
AND GOT THEM CANCELED I OFTEN
FOUND IT CONFUSING EVEN AS A
LAWYER IN A POLICY EXPERT TO
NAVIGATE THIS SYSTEM- I OFTEN
STRUGGLE TO RESOLVE PROBLEMS OF
MY OWN LOAN SERVICER OVER THE
YEARS AND FOUND THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES CONFUSING. SO IT'S
HARD TO OVERSTATE THE ACUTE NEED
PEOPLE HAVE FOR CLEAR AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION REMINDERS
ABOUT KEY DEADLINES
OPPORTUNITIES TO ATTEND EVENTS
AND ASK QUESTIONS OF EXPERTS.
AND BETTER AWARENESS OF HOW TO
FILE COMPLAINTS WHEN THEY CANNOT
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM ON THEIR
OWN. IN FACT ONE OF OUR OWN
EMPLOYEES A D. F. P. I RECENTLY
HAD AN IMPASSE WITH HER
SERVICER. TRYING TO ACCESS THE%
WAIVER AFTER SHE FILED A FORMAL
COMPLAINT WITH OUR DEPARTMENT
OUR STUDENT LOAN TEAM GOT
INVOLVED SHE WAS ABLE TO RESOLVE
THE MATTER WITH HER SERVICER AND
SHE RECEIVED MORE THAN FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DEBT
CANCELLATION. UNDER THE PSLF
WAIVER BECAUSE WE WERE THERE TO
HELP WE WANT TO HELP INSURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT LOAN BORROWING
CALIFORNIA CAN SUCCESSFULLY
MANAGE THEIR LOANS. AND THE
PUBLIC SERVANTS LIKE OUR OWN
STATE EMPLOYEES WITH FEDERAL
LOANS CAN ACCESS THE BENEFITS OF
PSLF AGAIN EXPANDED ACCESS THAT
WILL EXPIRE ON OCTOBER THIRTY
FIRST. SO THIS PROPOSAL WILL
HELP US SCALE UP RESULTS LIKE
THIS EXPANDING OUR- OUTREACH.
OUTREACH CAPACITIES OF THE
BORROWER KNOW THEY CAN TURNTO
US AS A RESOURCE. WHILE ALSO
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALIZED COUNSELING OR
LEGAL ADVICE TO BORROWERS
DIRECTLY. WILL STOP THERE WERE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THIS IS A VERY TIMELY
ISSUE MY TWITTER FEED IS BLOWING
UP ABOUT CANCELING STUDENT DEBT
TODAY AND- BIDEN HAS A PROPOSAL
. IF FOR THOSE YOU LOVE US THE
PODCAST THE DAILY YESTERDAY THEY
HAD A BIG EPISODE ON THE STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS AND WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN SHOULD DO. THE ONE THING
THAT THAT STRUCK ME AS THEY SAID
THAT A LOT OF THE SERVICING
COMPANIES HAVE JUST KIND OF.
QUIT THIS BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
ANY BUSINESS THE LAST TWO YEARS
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO. WE DON'T
KNOW WHO THE FOUR MILLION OR SO
PEOPLE ARE IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT
TRUE THAT THEY DON'T THEY'RE NOT
. PROPERLY SO EVEN IF THEY
STARTED TODAY. EVEN THE
GOVERNMENT SIDE WE WANT TO START
COLLECTING STUDENT AT AGAIN.
WILL MAKE NECESSARILY HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE KNOW WHO THESE
FOLKS ARE BECAUSE THE SERVER.
SERVICING COMPANIES. WALKED AWAY
SO HOW WILL THIS. PLAY WITH
COMMUNICATING WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS WELL THIS IS PART OF
THE SOURCE OF CONFUSION THE MANY
BORROWERS HAVE ABOUT THEIR
OPTIONS THERE ARE SOME LOAN
SERVICERS THAT ARE EXITING THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM AND OTHERS THAT
ARE. ENTERING SO THERE ACTUALLY
ARE TRANSFERS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW WE WORK ON WITH A MULTI
STATE TEAM AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO MONITOR LOAN
TRANSFERS- ABOUT SIXTEEN
MILLION. FARMERS NATIONWIDE ARE
BEING TRANSFERRED FROM ONE
SERVICE OR TO ANOTHER SO
BORROWERS ARE GOING TO LAND
SOMEWHERE WITH A NEW SERVICE OR
THERE ARE STILL. COMPANIES AND
IN CONTRACT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT THE FACT OF THE
TRANSFER. THE POSSIBILITY FOR
MISSED PAPERWORK ETCETERA DOES
MAKE THIS TIME A PARTICULARLY-
PARTICULARLY VEXING FOR BARBERS
WHO ARE GETTING MESSAGES FROM
YOU COMPANIES THEY DON'T KNOW
WHO TO TRUST AND AGAIN THERE. IS
AN OVERALL MISTRUST OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE OF
HOW THEY'VE MISMANAGED THE
STUDENT ON SYSTEM SO- WE HAVE A
ROLE THAT WE CAN PLAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS THE STATE
REGULATOR LITTLE CLOSER TO HOME.
TO HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND-
NOTICES YOUR NEW SERVICER YOU
KNOW HERE'S WHERE YOU SEND YOURPAYMENT- AND ALSO AGAIN IF THEY-
NEED TO HAVE RESOLVED A PROBLEM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THEY CAN FILE
A FORMAL COMPLAINT WITH US AND
WE CAN INVESTIGATE. MMHM SO THE
NOTION HERE IS THAT THE FOUR
BILLION. PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO HAD THEIR STUDENT DEBT SENSI
FROZEN THE PAST FOUR YEARS THEY
DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY'RE GONNA
GET TURNED BACK ON BUT YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW
ABOUT OTHER FORGIVENESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT HOW THAT WHY
WOULD THAT WHY WOULD THEY EVEN
DO THAT IF THE AND THEY'RE
THINKING WELL THEY MAY NEVER GO
BACK AND- START COLLECTING MY
DAD BECAUSE YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SAYING WE SHOULD CANCEL THE
DEBT AND SO WE KEEP DELAYING
THIS SO. IS NOT ALSO A MIXED
MESSAGE. I THINK THE MESSAGE
FROM US CAN CAN AND SHOULD BE
CLEAR AND CONSISTENT AND
ACCURATE ABOUT THE CURRENT STATE
OF PLAY. AND WE'VE ALREADY HELD
A COUPLE OF FANS WOULD LOVE TO
EXPAND OUR CAPACITY TO DO MORE
OUTREACH. TO BAR WAS TO SAY
HERE'S THE CURRENT STATE OF
THINGS HERE THE CURRENT
DEADLINES AS WE KNOW THEM HERE'S
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT HOW TO
ACCESS. ON THESE EXPANDED
BENEFITS BETWEEN NOW AND I'M
PARTICULARLY THAT PSLF DIED
THAT'S NOT A HARD DEADLINE. FROM
CONGRESS THAT WILL EXPIRE ON
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST AND AGAIN
ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR THE
GOVERNMENT. QUALIFIES FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND MAY NOT KNOW HOW TO
ACCESS AND HOW TO RAISE THEIR
HAND TO CERTIFY THE FOR ELIGIBLE
SO. THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE IN THE STATE THAT WE CAN
HELP AS THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
REGULATOR TO NAVIGATE THESE
CHOPPY WATERS. OKAY YEAH. GET
SOMEONE ARRESTED HELLO MISTER
ABOUT. DOES ANY OF THIS EVER
INCLUDING EDUCATION CAMPAIGN SO
THAT STUDENTS DON'T GET
THEMSELVES INTO THIS SITUATION
IN THE FIRST PLACE BECAUSE WE
WERE DEALING WITH THE RESULT NOT
NECESSARILY THE CAUSE. IN WILLIS
EVER STOP IN THIS WE EDUCATE
PEOPLE. ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WHEN THEY SIGN OFF ON THESE
LOANS. WELL THIS PROPOSAL REALLY
IS TARGETED AT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN OUT STUDENT DEBT
AND ARE IN REPAYMENT THAT SAID
ARE YOU KNOW WE WOULD LOVE TO DO
OUTREACH TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
STUDENT BORROWERS CURRENTLY
TODAY SO THAT THEY CAN TAKE
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES-
UNFORTUNATELY. YOU KNOW UNTIL
THERE IS. INVESTMENT IN
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
SUCH THAT WE WOULD REDUCE
TUITION. MOST FAMILIES TODAY
SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO GO TO
EDUCATION WITHOUT WITHOUT TAKING
A LONG UNNING REALITY WE REALLY
NEED TO HEAR MISTER CHAIR
CERTAINLY ADDRESS THOSE WHO ARE
IN A TOUGH SPOT. BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO EDUCATE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE WALKING INTO- ON THE
FRONT END BECAUSE- OTHERWISE IT
WILL NEVER STOP. RIGHT SAID THE
SERVER NAME WE NEED TO DO A LOT
FOR HERE QUITE FRANKLY YES.
ADDRESS THE DEBT BUT ALSO.
EDUCATE PEOPLE AS TO WHAT
THEY'RE SIGNING OFF ON WHAT WHAT
THE ALTAMONT- IN IMPLICATION OF
WHAT WHAT THAT WILL DO THEM IN
LONG TERM. PERHAPS THIS WE GET
PASSED OUR FINANCIAL AID REFORM.
AND THEN HAVING DEBT FREE
COLLEGE THAT PEOPLE NOT.
BORROWING MONEY THAT THERE DOES
NOT FREE COLLEGE THEY HAVE TO
PAY- THEIR FAMILY SHARE. THEY
GET THEIR CAL GRANT AND THEY
GET- A LITTLE BIT MORE MONEY FOR
STATEMENT FOR THEIR HOUSING
ALLOWANCE I THINK IT'S LESS THAN
A BILLION DOLLARS WERE SAYING
THAT. AND THEN WE WOULD YOU
KNOW. BASICALLY CUT OFF THAT
NEED TO BE TO BORROW MONEY GOING
FORWARD SO. THAT'S A- THING ON
OUR TO DO LISTS FOR- AND- MR
MEDINA IS PUSHING THAT BILL AND
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT- SO THIS
IS THE ISSUE WE WILL. HOLDS
OPENED ITS ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
SO WE ARE NOT GOING TO HEAR THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ISSUE YEAH
PUBLIC COMMENT AND TRYING TO GET
TO OTHER COMMITTEES NOW. SO WE
WILL NOW PROCEED WITH PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
LEADING DEMOCRAT YOU HAVE A PUMP
COMMENT PLEASE. ONE ZERO.
DO A FEW THAT HAVE QUEUED UP ON
MY MOTHER GIVEN THEIR LINE
NUMBER. OKAY. FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS CODY
MANNION AND I'M CALLING IN FROM
THE STUDENT DEBT CRISIS CENTER
WE- AND WITH ABOUT TWO MILLION
SUPPORTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND- HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- I'M
CALLING IN BECAUSE I AM ASKING
FOR SUPPORT FOR GIFT. HE IS
PROPOSED- STUDENT LOAN BORROWER
ASSISTANCE PLAN- AS SOMEONE WHO
SPOKE TO THOUSANDS OF BORROWERS
OVER THE YEARS AND HEARD ABOUT
THE MANY OBSTACLES THEY FACE I
KNOW- THE STUDENT LOAN SYSTEM IS
FAR TOO CONVOLUTED AND COMPLEX
FOR THE AVERAGE BAR TO NAVIGATE
WITHOUT ASSISTANCE- THERE ARE
EXISTING RESOURCES PROVIDED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION BUT
THEY'RE INSUFFICIENT AND THEY
STILL LEAVE SO MANY GAPS FOR
BORROWERS TO BE TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF- BY PREDATORY- DEBT RELIEF
SCAMS AND OTHER FOR PROFIT
ENTITIES- SO. WITH ALL OF THE
COMPLEXITY THAT OBSTACLES PARTS
OF TASTE AND ALL OF THE HARM
CAUSED BY THE PANDEMIC I BELIEVE
IN OUR ORGANIZATION BELIEVES
THAT NOW IS THE TIME TO INVEST
IN SUPPORTING SYSTEMS FOR
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS THROUGH
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND SO-
D. F. P. I. HAS CREATED A PLAN-
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED- HIS
OWN BUDGETARY RECOMMENDATION WE
BELIEVE THAT. THAT PROPOSED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS- SHOULD ACTUALLY
BE TRIPLED BECAUSE WE HAVE FOUR
MILLION STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS
IN THIS COUNTRY EVERY DOLLAR WE
INVEST IN SUPPORTING HEIR
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS AROUND
STUDENT LOAN DEBT NOT ONLY.
HELPS IMPROVE AND INCREASE THEIR
FINANCIAL WELLNESS BUT ACTUALLY-
PROVIDES DIVIDENDS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THESE ARE
WORDS ARE LIFTED OUT OF STUDENT
LOAN DELINQUENCY AND DEFAULT TO
THEIR FINANCIAL WELLNESS IS
IMPROVED ARE ABLE TO FULLY
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR ECONOMY- SO THIS IS
THANK YOU. WELL AND JUSTICE THAT
WE HAD A PREMATURE- SPEAKER
THERE JUST. WE HAVE- PUBLIC HERE
ON THE PHONE AND IT. WE'RE GOING
TO DO IN PERSON FIRST YOU CAN
YOU CAN COME BACK HERE JUST IT'S
ONE MINUTE- LAST SIXTY SECONDS
OR LAST FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
WILL GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR REBEKAH CURLY ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITY
COALITION REPRESENTING ABOUT TWO
THIRDS. OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE- WE
SUGGEST THAT YOU ACTUALLY DON'T
NEED TO PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROJECTS IN
THE STUDENT HOUSING ITEM. OUR
REQUEST IS THAT YOU FIND ALL
TWELVE OF THE ELIGIBLE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROJECTS THAT WERE
DEEMED ELIGIBLE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THOSE
OF THE PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE THE
SEVEN ADDITIONAL ON PAGE SIX IN
THE ANALYSIS. THAT WOULD TAKE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO MILLION ADDITIONAL DOLLARS.
I'M ALL OF THESE PROJECTS DO
MEET THE AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND PRIORITIES THAT
ARE IN THE STATUTE SB ONE SIXTY
NINE. WHICH WE KNOW IS A TOP
GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM- SOME OF
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN DEEMED
ELIGIBLE BUT NOT RECOMMENDED BY.
FOR FUNDING BY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO MEET SOME OF THOSE
OTHER KEY PRIORITIES SUCH AS
BEING SHOVEL READY. I'M AS A
BACK UP IF THERE'S NOT AN%
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
AVAILABLE YOU CAN CERTAINLY
ADVANCE FUND FROM THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR APPLICATION
THAT'S BEING DISCUSSED BUT I
WANT TO REALLY MAKE THE POINT
THAT DELAYED DOES HARM VIABLE
PROJECTS A COST ESCALATION IS
NOT AN ABSTRACTION. WE'VE SEEN
COSTS INCREASED BY ABOUT TEN TO
FIFTEEN PERCENT. IN MANY REGIONS
OF THE STATE OVER THE LAST YEAR
THAT MEANS FEWER BEDS WITH THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ROB FROST ON THE SUPERINTENDENT
PRESIDENT AT NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE
AND I ALSO REPRESENT THE MEMBERS
OFTHE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT HOUSING
COALITION THEY'LL BE SEVERAL
OTHERS HERE TODAY TO PRESENT. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING WHAT SHE DESCRIBED
AS THE MASSIVE NEED. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGESTUDENTS. NAPA VALLEY
COLLEGE IS ONE OF THE CURRENT
ELIGIBLE COLLEGES WERE A P.
THREE COLLEGE WE ASKED FOR
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS SO
IT'S NOT. AN AMAZING PRESENT AS
AS YOU DESCRIBED EARLY. EARLIER
AND WE ARE SHOVEL READY. NAPA
VALLEY COLLEGE IS DONE THREE
FEASIBILITY STUDIES INDICATE
THAT WE NOT ONLY HAVE UNMET NEED
FOR HOUSING BUT A DEMAND. FOR
HOUSING AS WELL AND OUR MOST
RECENT STUDY. SHOWS THAT THE
DEMAND IS ACTUALLY INCREASING.
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC TIME. IN
ADDITION TO AWARDING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
CONSTRUCTION GRANTS AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOU CONSIDER AWARDING
CONSTRUCTION GRANTS. TO ALL
ELIGIBLE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROJECTS. LIKE OURS THAT ARE
READY. WITH A NEW INVESTMENT TO
ADDRESS TO AFFORDABILITY IN THE
NEEDS OF HOUSING INSECURE
STUDENT. POPULATIONS NAPA VALLEY
COLLEGEIS DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR
PER PER APPROPRIATION
CONSIDERATION FOR A CONSTRUCTION
ROUTE HOWEVER IT WASN'T INCLUDED
BECAUSE WHEN WE HAD INCLUDED
FAMILY HOUSING. IN OUR FORMULA
AND THAT FAMILY HOUSING ADDITION
WHICH WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED THE
HOUSELESS STUDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY ACTUALLY LOWERED US ON
THE WEIGHTED RANKING THAT WAS
DESCRIBED EARLIER BY THE L. A.
O. OFFICE. RIVER TRAIL VILLAGE
AT NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE OUR
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECT WILL
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR DIVERSE
STUDENTS INCLUDING VETERANS
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS ATHLETES
AND FAMILIES BUT WE HAVE A
DEMOGRAPHIC VARIANCE IN PLACE
FOR EVERY YEAR. TWO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LONG HEARING DRIVER
FROM NAPA SO I DOUBLED YOUR TIME
BUT WE HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
WAS WORTH IT THANK YOU. WE WILL
BE ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE AND IN
THAT GREATER INVESTMENT IN THE
NEAR FUTURE TO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MCCARTY APPRECIATE THE
TIME MY NAME IS WILLIE DUNCAN ON
THE SUPERINTENDENT PRESIDENT OF
SIERRA COLLEGE AND I'M GOING TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS ARE
SPEAKING ABOUT STUDENT HOUSING
ALSO. AND I WOULD. ALSO MAKE
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE FIVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROJECTS THAT
WERE RECOMMENDED FOR FUNNY BY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLUS THE
SEVEN ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROJECTS THAT WERE
ELIGIBLE BUT NOT RECOMMENDED ALL
BE FUNDED I WITH AN ADDITIONAL
PROCREATION OF THREE AND THIRTY
TWO MILLION ADDED TO WHAT- AS
ALREADY BEEN. RECOMMENDED I'M
AND I WOULD JUST SAY SPEAKING
ABOUT THIS YEAR COLLEGE PROJECT
IN PARTICULAR ON THIS A SHOVEL
READY PROJECT WE'VE DONE A
FEASIBILITY STUDY THERE IS
DEMAND IN OUR AREA ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY OUR PROJECT WAS
RANKED HIGHLY WAS B. WE WERE
ABLE TO- PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND PROMISE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOWN TO ALMOST THE 50%
LEVEL- IN OUR AREA- IT'S A THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE BED
FACILITY AND A KEY COMPONENT OF
OUR STUDENT SUCCESS INITIATIVE-
TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR INDIVIDUALS IN OUR COMMUNITY
SO THEY CAN. ACTUALLY CONTINUE
THEIR COLLEGE. CAREER AND I WORK
TOWARDS GETTING A DEGREE OR
TRANSFERRING ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. HELLO THANK YOU
TERM AND MCCARTY. MY NAME IS DR
SHARPER LESS TIME WITH COLLEGE
OF THE SIXTIES. AND I MYSELF IN
SOLIDARITY WITH ALL THE OTHER
CALIFORNIA MANY COLLEGE CEOS. I
AM EMPHASIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
APPROVING ALL OF THE PROPOSED
HOUSING PROJECTS. CULTURE THIS
ISSUES IS LOCATED IN SINCE YOU
COUNTY WHICH IS THE SIZE OF
MARYLAND. AND WE HAVE ABOUT
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND IN
POPULATION BUT 17% POVERTY RATE.
THE COUNTY IS NOT ONLY FACED
WITH INCLEMENT WEATHER
CONDITIONS WHICH MAKE THE
COMMUTE TO THE COLLEGE
CHALLENGING. BUT IS ALSO
EXPERIENCING HOUSING INVENTORY
SHORTAGES DUE TO DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. ADDITIONALLY DUE TO
ITS RELOCATION THE COUNTY
SCHOLARSHIP INFRASTRUCTURE
CANNOT SUPPORT THE SUCCESS OF
LOCAL STUDENTS ENGAGING IN
ONLINE LEARNING. IN ORDER FOR
SISKIYOU TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
HIS COMMUNITY AND TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF AND REPRESENTED
STUDENTS SERVED. IT IS VITAL
THAT THE HOUSING GRANTS IS
APPROVED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. KEEP CURRY
COUNTY COLLEGE PRESIDENT CEO
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THIS ISSUE KAMIKAZ THE LISTS WE
SAID WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE-
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
DISTAL PROJECTS WHICH INCLUDES
CARPET COLLEGE THE REASON WHY
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT ADVOCATE FOR
GOING TO COLLEGE IS THAT THERE'S
NOT ONE CAN BE BECAUSE MERCED
COUNTY I WAS AWARDED ON THE
CONSTRUCTION GRANTS FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU WILL FUND ALL ELIGIBLE
PROJECTS. INCLUDING COUNTY
COLLEGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE WERE BUSH PRESIDENT TO
SOME IS RIVER COLLEGE HERE
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU- CHAIR
MCCARTY C. R. C.'S TONIGHT MOST
OF VERSE COMMUNICATORS IN THE
NATION BUT THE MAJORITY OF OUR
STUDENTS BEING FIRST GENERATION
LOW INCOME AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
CRC IS A MODEL AND COMMUNICATE A
SYSTEM FOR THE INNOVATIVE
PRACTICES RELATING TO STUDENT
EQUITY AND GUIDED PATHWAYS TO
CRCS SHOVEL READY HOUSING
PROJECTS THE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN BAD IN NINETY TWO UNITS
THAT HAS BEEN DESIGNATED TO
SUPPORT TRADITIONAL AND
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS
INCLUDING STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENTS. GIVEN OUR STUDENT
POPULATION COUPLE WITH A
COLLEGES D. WORK WITH STUDENT
EQUITY AND STUDENT BASIC NEEDS
DOES HOUSING PROJECT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OUR EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE OVERALL STUDENT
SUCCESS RATES WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY CLOSING THE GAP
IN ACHIEVEMENT C. R. C. AS AN
ELIGIBLE BUT NOT FUNDED LISTS
WITH THIS WITH MINOR WORRIES IN
MIND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER FUNDING
FALL ELIGIBLE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROJECTS. THANK YOU. MY
AMERISPEC I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
TO STIR SERVICES THAT STEINORTH
A JUNIOR COLLEGE- MY COLLEGE
REPORTS FUNDING FOR A PROPOSED
AN ELIGIBLE STUDENT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. INCLUDING
OUR COLLEGES NEAR SHOVEL READY
THROUGH HOUSING FACILITY. OVER A
THOUSAND. AT SANTA ROSA JUNIOR
COLLEGE LOST THEIR HOMES IN
RECENT WILDFIRES. CURRENTLY 20%
OF OUR STUDENTS ARE HOUSING
INSECURE HOMELESS. TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE- MY COLLEGE IS IN THE
PROCESS OF CONSTRUCTING A SHOVEL
READY. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO-
BET ON CAMPUS STUDENT HOUSING
FACILITY. WHAT PRIORITY GIVEN TO
LOW INCOME STUDENTS HOMELESS
STUDENTS FOSTER YOUTH VETERANS
AND THOSE WITH DISABILITIES. ARE
WE ARE PARTNERED WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING FOR
THIRTY FOUR LOW INTEREST
FINANCING OR PRO OR PLAN RENTS
ARE BELOW MARKET RATE. BUT STILL
TOO HIGH TO BE AFFORDABLE TO
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS. ARE THE SB
ONE SIXTEEN OUR PROGRAM PROVIDES
A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY. TO
IMPROVE THE CENTER WAS AT YOUR
COLLEGE OUR PROJECT WE ARE
REQUESTING. FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PROJECT. TO DIRECTLY
REDUCE THE RENTS 420% OF OUR
BEDS TO MAKE THIS A TRULY
AFFORDABLE PROJECT FOR STUDENTS.
ARE THERE WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE
WITHOUT THE STATE SUPPORT FOR A
PROJECT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING TIME TO CONSIDER THIS
REQUEST I AM RANDALL ROLES
SOCIAL VICE CHANCELLOR FOR THE
CURRENT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT HERE ON BEHALF
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE. BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE HAS IDENTIFIED A
SUBSTANTIAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NEED WITHIN ITS STUDENT
POPULATION WHICH HAS OVER 67% OF
ITS STUDENTS EXPRESSING SOME
KIND OF HOUSING AND SECURITY.
ALSO THE METROPOLITAN
BAKERSFIELD AREA HAS AN
APARTMENT VACANCY RELATED RATE
BELOW 1% THE PROPOSED
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECT IS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR BEDS IT WILL BE READY
TO BREAK GROUND IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WILL FOCUS ON
EMANCIPATED FORMER FOSTER CARE
STUDENTS VETERANS STUDENTS AND
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY OR
IMMINENTLY FACING HOMELESSNESS.
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET PRESENTS A RARE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HOUSING CRISIS
THROUGH THE SOLUTION THAT
PROVIDES STUDENTS SUPPORTABILITY
HOUSING WITH DIGNITY AND A
COMMITMENT TO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS IN SHORT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT SUPPORTS
FUNDING ALL OF THE PROPOSED IN
THE INTELLIGIBLE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION GRANT
PROJECTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OUTSIDE NO OKAY THANK
YOU WILL NOW PROCEED TO OUR
CALLERS ON THE PHONE- MODERATOR.
I JST TO OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOLKS THANKS FOR COMING- TODAY-
GOOD TO SEE PEOPLE IN PERSON AND
AS YOU KNOW THIS IS A PRIORITY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE SO STAY
TUNED THANK YOU. OR OPERATOR
PLEASE- PROCEED WITH THE CALLERS
ON THE PHONE. WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HELLO LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS WERE
POLICY ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND NONPROFIT. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FROM DF
PI FOR OUTREACH TO STUDENT
BORROWERS AT LEAST 23% OF
NONPROFIT EMPLOYEES HAD
SIGNIFICANT STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
THIS DEBT HAMPERS THE ABILITY OF
THE SECTOR TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
RETAIN THE WORK FORCE WHICH
ACCOUNTS FOR ONE IN FOURTEEN
JOBS STATEWIDE. IN JANUARY WE
HOSTED A WEAPON ARE ON THE
PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM WE HAD OVER THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE REGISTER FOR THE
WEAPON ARE AND MORE THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED NONPROFITS PARTICIPATE
NONPROFIT STAFF PARTICIPATED. WE
BELIEVE THIS RESPONSE TO OUR ONE
WEAPON ARE WAS JUST THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG THE NEED FOR THIS
INFORMATION IS DIRE AND TIMES OF
THE ABSENCE WITH THE WAIVER
EXPIRING IN OCTOBER.
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO RESPOND TO
THIS NEED AND FEDERAL OUTREACH
OUTREACH IS NOT ENOUGH IT MAKES
GOOD SENSE FOR DS PAI TO TAKE
THE LEAD IN ENSURING THAT OUR
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM. GIVEN THE IMPORTANT.
THIS THIS REQUEST WILL PROVIDE
SUB GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO REACH
COMMUNITIES THAT THE F. P. I
CAN'T REACH. AND GIVEN THAT SUB
GRANTING FUNCTION WE BELIEVE THE
BUDGET CHANGE SHOULD ACTUALLY BE
FOR THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS-
INSTEAD OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WE ASK FOR YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BUDGET ITEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER PLACE. OUR NEXT
SPEAKER COMES FROM A LINE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CARE MCCARTY MEDINA SAID
LOOK AT THAT AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE END OF THE SCHOOL.
BOARD IN ADDITION THAT WORKS
WITH YOUNG ADULTS WE SEE THAT
THEY ARE HURTING CONFUSED AND
DON'T HAVE STUDENT DEBT
BORROWERS SYSTEM. THE FOUR
MILLION CASH CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENT BORROWERS ARE HURTING.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS CONSISTENTLY
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS OF THE
COMPLEX STUDENT LOAN SYSTEM.
ALTHOUGH BARLEY ARE REGULARLY
ADVISED TO CONTACT THER SERVICE
OR FOR ASSISTANCE WITH THEIR
LOVE. NEARLY A DECADE OF STATE
AND FEDERAL INVESTIGATION INTO
THESE COMPANIES INCLUDING BY THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY. GENERAL AND
FINANCIAL REGULATOR. I HAVE MADE
CLEAR THAT THE COMPANIES CANNOT
BE TRUSTED TO PROVIDE ACCURATE
BY. FOR ALL THESE REASONS THE
FOR STATEWIDE OUTREACH EDUCATION
IT'S- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS THE FBI
BUDGET REQUEST AFTER TO BE
TRICKLED AFFECTIVELY REACH FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PLACE. OUR NEXT BIGGER COMES
FROM THE LINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
IS THE THING THAT'S WHAT I
THOUGHT WERE CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION. FOR ASKING
FOR AN APPROPRIATION OF TWENTY
MILLION TO EXTEND THE FUNDING OF
THE CURRENT GRANTEES TO CONTINUE
THE EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT PROGRAM. ENGLISH
LEARNER ROAD MAP POLICY
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT PROGRAM THE
PANDEMIC HAS INCREASED THE NEED
FOR A MORE ROBUST ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY INSTRUCTION FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS THROUGH THE GRANT
PROGRAM. MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
NOT AWARE OF THE CALIFORNIA. E.
L. ROAD MAP POLICY. THERE
CONTINUE TO BE URGING NEED. FOR
IMPLEMENTATION BY CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND EDUCATORS IN
ORDER TO ASSURE ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS WILL BE PROVIDED WITH
AN EFFECTIVE AND QUALITY
EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. OUR NEXT SPEAKER COMES
FROM THE LINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO
MY NAME IS JENNY MAY AND I AM
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION OF THE
CELL BUDGET IN PARTICULAR THE
FUNDS DEDICATED TO EXPANDING THE
AVAILABILITY. OF A FREE ONLINE
ADAPTIVE LEARNING HOMEWORK
SYSTEM. SUCH SYSTEMS ARE
CRITICAL TOOLS TO SUPPORT STEM
EDUCATION AND EXPANDING FREE
ACCESS TO SUCH THE PHONE BECAUSE
ALL THREE SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION BENEFITS ALL STUDENTS
NOT JUST THOSE WHO ARE TAKING
ONLINE COURSES. IN OTHER WORDS
INCREASE ACCESS TO DIGITAL
RESOURCE THE THIRD BALL STUDENTS
AND THE INCREASED AVAILABILITY
OF SUCH SYSTEM BUT NO COST TO
REMOVE THE BARRIERS TO CREATING
ZERO TEXTBOOK COST DEGREES ND
CERTIFICATES. FURTHERMORE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND IMPACTFUL WAY
OF EXPANDING THE AVAILABILITY OF
SUCH RESOURCES IS THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH INVOLVING
ALL THREE SEGMENTS OF POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. LIKE THE
WORK ALREADY INITIATED. WITH
SELF FUNDS THANK YOU. MORE THANK
YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE MORE OUR
NEXT IS LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ARE CHAIR
MARK MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY WRESTLERS AND
I'M KERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT- ECHOING THE WORDS OF-
MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE- COLLEAGUES
TO URGE YOU TO FIND ALL OF THE
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS- I ALSO WOULD
SAY THAT- THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
CONSIDER THOSE PROJECTS THAT
WERE DEEMED INELIGIBLE- LOOKING
AT WHY THEY MIGHT BE. HAVE BEEN
DEEMED INELIGIBLE BECAUSE SOME
OF THOSE PROJECTS MAY ALSO BE
SHOVEL READY AND ACTUALLY MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS- OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU. THE NEW. OUR NEXT SPEAKER COMES FROM A
LINE THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
EDWARD NUMBER ZERO I AM A
PROFESSOR IN COMPUTER SCIENCE
JOURNAL CAMINO COLLEGE IN
TORRANCE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNISTIC
MISTER CHAIR YEAH BUT IT'S NOT
COMING UP TO CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SUPPORTING OUR- BUDGET
RESTORATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL LEARNING LABORATORY.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON A
LEARNING LAB ON A PROJECT WHERE
WE ARE TRANSFORMING. OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGH A PROFICIENCY
BASED LEARNING MASTERY LEARNING
AND E SEE NOT ONLY A
SIGNIFICANT SUCCESSES INCLUDING.
LEARNING GAPS IN EQUITY GAPS.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL BUT
ALSO BEING ABLE TO COLLABORATE
WITH OUR CALCINED- YOU SEE
COMMUNITY IN ADDITION WE'VE ALSO
BEEN ABLE PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO ACTUALLY BE
PART OF A RESEARCH OPPORTUNITY
WHICH DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY OFTEN
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR A THAT
ADDITIONAL- SUPPORT. AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE BUDGET RESTORED
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE. OUR
NEXT SPEAKER COMES FROM A LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MATHIS
SAYING THE NEXT THING CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TEN
MILLION FOR THE FBI TO CONDUCT A
STUDENT BORROWER OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN WE WILL HAVE
TO REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE FOR A
TOTAL OF THIRTY MILLION. IF IT
ALONE SYSTEM IS TOO CONVOLUTED
AND INFLUX FOR THE AVERAGE BAR
TO NAVIGATE IT WITHOUT
ASSISTANCE FROM HER TO ADOPT
FROM ADITYA EARLIER EXISTING
RESOURCES ARE ALSO INSUFFICIENT
TO ASSIST BORROWERS WHO NEED
HELP DECADE THE STATE AND
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS INTO LOAN
SERVICER COMPANIES INCLUDING BY
OUR OWN CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE MADE CLEAR THAT
THESE COMPANIES. CANNOT BE
TRUSTED TO PROVIDE ACCURATE
ADVICE AND THE LEGISLATURE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LAST YEAR'S
RIGHTLY WAITIN AND PAST CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS ALONG THIS LINE
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS- STATE
BUDGET THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
CREATED A STUDENT AT WORK GROUP
LED BY. THE CITY COMMISSION AND
THE WORKERS TOP RECOMMENDATION
IDENTIFIED THE FBI AS THE LEAD
AGENCY TO SUPPORT BARS AND MANY
OF THE ELEMENTS OF GIFT CARDS
PLANTS ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE
WORKGROUPS RECOMMENDATION FOR
ALL THE ABOVE REASONS THE
PROPOSED TEN MILLION
APPROPRIATION SHOULD BE TRIPLE
TO THIRTY MILLION AND. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I NEXT
BECOMES IN LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DANIEL GOOD TERRACE ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF-CALIFORNIA IS A STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE STUDENT BORROWER
ASSISTANCE FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE ALLOCATION FURTHER
EXPANDED CHRISTIAN BARRING AN
AVERAGE EDUCATION. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT BIG COMES IN LINE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS ALEX NOT A SERVICE THE CHAIR
OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
MUSEUM SOON ASSOCIATION I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ENSURING STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WELL THE BEST THE BEST
WAY TO ENSURE THAT IS TO PASS A
B. SEVENTEEN POINT SIX. AND
IMPLEMENT THE CAL GRANT EQUITY-
FRAMEWORK THAT TAKES FINANCIAL
AID COALITION IS WORKING ON.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT QUESTION OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME AGAIN AND STOOD
BY THE PRESIDENT THAT YOU CAN
DIEGO I URGE YOU PLEASE SUPPORT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU CAN
DIEGO RECEIVED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR AFRICA
ANYWAY STUDENT HOUSING PROJECT.
OFF CAMPUS HOUSING HERE IN THE
WEALTHY WHITE BEACHFRONT
NEIGHBORHOOD OF WHAT WHY IS
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE AND
VERY HARD TO COME BY FOR
STUDENTS. THE PROJECT WOULD
PROVIDE THE HUNDRED YOU BET NEAR
TRANSIT FOR THE STUDENTS WHO
NEED IT MOST. THIS WAY YOU CAN
GET A PLAN HOW LONG THE FADING
CARE LEVIN HUNDRED OF OUR
NEEDIEST CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENT BY REDUCING THE RENT. I
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
PLEASE HELP YOU CAN YOU GOT
DIDN'T WE CANNOT AFFORD THE
HOUSING HERE LOCALLY. THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH OF IT AND WE NEED
HELP. THAT THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
BECOMES FROM LINE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS LANA CRITICIZE MANY
STUDENTS STUDYING AND LIVING AT
UC SAN DIEGO- I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU
SAN DIEGO RECEIVED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR PUBLICATION RESPITE
HOUSING PROJECT- IF APPROVED THE
FUNDING WILL ALLOW US TO BUILD A
ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN BEDS AS WELL AS PROVIDE-
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED. OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST NEW STUDENTS
ARE RENTERS COUNT OF
APPROXIMATELY 50% BELOW CURRENT
MARKET RATES ON THIS IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT ARE OFF CAMPUS
HOUSING IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND
VERY SLIM- AND LOOK WHERE WHERE
YOU FIFTY RESIDES- I CAMPUS
RINGS THIS PROJECT I WANTED TO
JUST SAY THAT. HAS AS MANY FROM
THE- AND JASMINE SAID HOUSING IS
REALLY REALLY OF NOT IMPORTANT
PART OF STUDENTS COLLEGE AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE AND SO WE
HOUSING. INMATES ASKED THANK YOU
. THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE. OUR
NEXT SPEAKER COMES FROM LIE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
EVERYONE- MY NAME IS RHIANNON
CALLAHAN NINE THE STUDENT AT UC
SAN DIEGO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LETTING ME BE HERE TODAY I AM
CALLING TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THE POS RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU
YOU CAN REVIEW THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. CARD
APPLICATION WHY DIDN'T HOUSING
PROJECT THAT WOULD PROVIDE ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED NEW VENTURE
UPPER DIVISION TRANSPORTATION.
WHICH MEANS BOTH OF THE STUDENTS
THAT WOULD AUTOMATICALLY BE
HAVING TO GO TO FIND. OUT CAMPUS
HOUSING. I FOR THOSE ARE OUT OF
LAW UP A YEAR. IT WOULD MEAN-
LOT THE COURT THE STUDENTS. YOU
CAN BE ABLE ALSO PUT THE PATH
ALONG SAVINGS COSTS REDUCE
STRESS FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. I BANG FOR YOUR SUPPORT I
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE HAPPY TO
CALCULATE. WHICH IS CHEAPER
PARKING TICKETS THAT YOU GET FOR
SLEEPING IN. YOUR CAR YOUR
CAMPUS ARE RIGHT. NO THERE'S NOT
MUCH MORE FACED WHEN AN IT
SHOULD NOT. SHOULD NOT BE A BIG
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT BIG AREN'T ANY BIGGER
COMES SOME OF MINE. IT COMES
FROM LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KATE AND LYNN AND I AM A STUDENT
STUDYING POLITICAL SCIENCE THAT
YOU CAN DIEGO. DID YOU CRITICAL.
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU SUSPEND
YEAGER RECEIVED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ITS ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED PLUS NEW
BEDSIN OUR PAPER CANYON WHAT
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECT. I'D
SEEN AND EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND
THE HOUSING CRUNCH THAT HAS
GREATLY AFFECTED STUDENTS IN SAN
DIEGO LET'S LET SOME STUDENTS
PAYING THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
LIVE IN LIVING ROOMS OR EVEN
WORSE RELEGATED TO LIVING IN
THEIR CARS. OFF CAMPUS HOUSING
IS CLEARLY VERY HARD TO COME BY
IN THE OIL AND OUR CAMPUS NEEDS
PROJECT TO HELP MAKE THE COST OF
COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT BIGGER
COMES FROM LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JACOB TWO MA'AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICE OF FINANCIAL POWER MEANT
PART OF THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
HERE IN THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO- CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE ALLOCATION OF
BUDGET FUNDS FOR STUDENT
BORROWERS SUPPORT TO THE FBI AND
I ECHO. THE REQUEST FROM
PREVIOUS CALLERS TO INCRASE
THAT FUNDING LEVEL TO THIRTY
MILLION WE CONDUCTED RESEARCH
JUST PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC WITH
THE FEDERAL RESERVE BANK OF SAN
FRANCISCO ON STUDENT LOAN
BORROWING AND REPAYMENT IN THE
BAY AREA. AND FOUND SKYROCKETING
LEVELS OF DEFAULT AND
DELINQUENCY. WITH ONE IN SIX
BORROWERS HAVING DEFAULTED AT
LEAST ONCE ON THEIR LOANS OVER
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS- THE
SITUATION IS CERTAINLY WORSE FOR
MANY OF US. DURING THE THIS
ECONOMIC CRISIS OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND EXISTING RESOURCES OR SIMPLY
AN ADEQUATE FOR THE SUPPORT THE
BORROWERS NEED SO. I REALLY HOPE
THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS INVESTMENT
AND THE FBI IS THE RIGHT PLACE
TO DO IT THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
BIGGER COMES FROM LINE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
TO MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS OUR
MONDO FOX FROM UC BERKELEY WHERE
I AM A COMPUTER SCIENCE
PROFESSOR AND ALSO A DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION OFFICER AND
IN CONJUNCTION WITH MY
COLLABORATOR PROFESSOR I'VE BEEN
AMBROSIA FROM EL CAMINO COLLEGE
WHO SPOKE VERY RECENTLY. AND
ALSO MY COLLABORATORS AT CAL
STATE LONG BEACH WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE RESTORATION OF
FUNDING TO THE CAL EDUCATION
LEARNING LAB. AFTER BRIDGES THAT
ARE LEARNING LAB PROJECT. IS
MAKING POSSIBLE MASTERY LEARNING
IT IS A TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECT
THAT IS CLOSING BURNING GAPS DUE
TO BOTH EQUITY AND STUDENT
DISABILITIES WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
ADDRESS THE REGION'S AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REGARDING
THIS WORK. AND CRITICALLY
FUNDING FOR THIS WORK IN A
LEARNING LAB COULD NOT HAVE COME
FROM ANYWHERE ELSE PRIVATE
FUNDING IS ONLY CHASING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE. PUBLIC
FUNDING FROM AGENCIES LIKE NSF
TENDS TO BE MORE INCREMENTAL
BUSINESS HIGH RISK BUT VERY HIGH
REWARD RESEARCH GREAT BANG FOR
THE BUCK. OVER TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS ALREADY- AFFECTED BY A
SUCCESS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
FUNDING BE RESTORED FOR THIS
UNIQUELY IMPORTANT PROGRAM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OUR NEXT
SPEAKER COMES FROM THE LINE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BELLIGERENT COMMITTEE COMMERCE
MINING DUMP ARSON ARE PROFESSOR
CHEMISTRY AT UC DAVIS AND
DIRECTOR THAT WE PROTECT.
MEDICAL FOR THE RESTORATION F
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION MARK LAUGHS WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE GAPS ARE MARXIST.
WE PROTECT PROJECT IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST AND MOST POPULAR OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCE PROJECT I'M
HERE TODAY SAYING STUDENTS MON
THE DOLLARS TODAY ASSEMBLY
INCREASE ADAPTIVE LEARNING LATIN
MISSION THE COUPLE WILL BE
STRICTLY AVAILABLE TEXTBOOKS
ALLOW STUDENTS
WELL RESOURCES TO STUDENTS THE
RESPECTIVE APPOINTMENTS OR
SYSTEM
IT'S. MODERATORS THAT IT READ
MORE SPEAKERS. WE HAVE ONE FINAL
SPEAKER WELCOME THE LINE AT
THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MY NAME IS MICHELLE KANSKE
BROCK AND I'M CALLING IN TO
SUPPORT THE RESTORATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION LEARNING
LAB FUNDING I'M A FACULTY MEMBER
AT FOOTHILL DE ANZA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. IMPROVING
ONLINE TEACHING ACROSS THE THREE
FIFTY CSU AND UC SYSTEM IS MORE
IMPORTANT TODAY THAN EVER. AS A
FACULTY MEMBER I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THE LEARNING LAB IS
SPENDING A VERY DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PROJECTS IN THOSE FUNDED BY
THE BLANKET FUNDS. THAT GO
DIRECTLY TO INSTITUTIONS. THREE
YEARS I'VE LED A LEARNING GRANT
. CALLED THE HUMANIZING ONLINE
STOMACH. WHICH IS TO CLOSE
EQUITY GAPS IN ONLINE COURSES
THROUGH CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
ONLINE TEACHING OUR PROJECT TO
POSITIVELY INFLUENCE THE
TEACHING OF EIGHTY TWO STEM
FACULTY AND SOME. SPECIALISTS
ACROSS THE PUBLIC SEGMENT. AND
THE LEARNING EXPERIENCES OF OVER
TEN THOUSAND ONLINE STUDENTS.
OUR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT OUR
PROJECT IS SHIFTING FACULTY
ATTITUDES PERCEPTIONS AND ONLINE%
TEACHING BEHAVIORS THAT RESULT
IN A MORE EQUITY NINETY
TEACHING IT IS ALREADY MOVING
UNDERGRADUATE ONLINE STEM
COURSES FROM OF WEED OUT CULTURE
TO CULTURE HERE. AND THIS IS A
CHANGE IN OUR STUDENTS NEED MORE
NOW THAN EVER AS WE ARE TWO
YEARS INTO A VIRAL AND RACIAL
PANDEMIC. THE LEARNING LAB IS
SERVING A ROLE THAT NO OTHER
ENTITY SERVES IN OUR STATE AND
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTION TO CALIFORNIA
PLEASE. RESTORE THEIR BUDGET
THANK YOU. OKAY THERE NEARLY
DOLLARS SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISTER.
THERE. OUR. THEY ARE. YEAH YEAH. EVEN NEED. RIGHT AWAY.
THEY ARE.